Hello everybody, sorry for- I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm
mad, I'm mad, I'm so mad, I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm
mad, I'm mad, I'm so fucking mad, I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm mad,
I'm so mad, I'm so angry right now, oh my god, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I had to deal with work stuff, oh my, I'm so mad
right now, oh my god, no, I'm actually gonna, I literally
shouldn't be, I was gonna I was gonna implode or like
self-sabotage something because I did not care anymore I was
so mad I can't say what it is I was just really fucking mad
and I messaged in the staff chat because um we just got it
is unrelated to the 3 plus hour I'm so sorry for being late
guys um I literally got out of a 3 plus hour uh work meeting
um and this Me being mad is unrelated to this, to the work
meeting.
But, like, I legitimately have been like, I've been up since
8 a.m.
working from, like, non-stop working from day to night.
Uh, give me a sec.
Okay.
Okay, sorry, sorry.
I just got another work message.
sorry, I'm, I'm mad.
I, um, so, uh, I've been, I, it's been a long day, guys.
It's been a very long day.
It's been a very, very fucking long day.
Um, so I literally just got out of the work meeting was
supposed to be, like, they said it was supposed to be max
three hours long.
And it went almost, it went super overtime, like 45 minutes.
is over time and so i did not have a lot of chance to like i
and i went back to work work on other stuff right after and
then i had to go straight into uh uh sorry
just more work messages
okay um all right fuck okay sorry
all right so the worst part was because um my staff were so
tired because i've you know my my manager is european and it
was way past his bedtime and he has i'm not his main work
like i'm just his hobby like him managing me is just a
little side project um because he has a real at a real real
job talking to real adults yeah it is a so um talking to
very important people that's not me oh you have the side
quest anyway so the meeting was took a long time and so he
went straight to bed right after uh because the meeting
ended like maybe like um around four uh 540 uh it ended
around 540 to 545 and so it was it's really late in eu at
that time and then my other staff member like my two my two
head staff members were not there so i had to handle the
important messages um because they needed a reply by the end
of the day and oh my gosh i was so mad i was so mad talking
that i legitimately told i i like texted my manager i don't
care about the the text price i don't care anymore because i
was so mad I texted my manager from EU and I literally wrote
Hey, I'm gonna self-sabotage and explode on them because no
one is stopping me just giving you a warning right now When
you see the aftermath And then in our staff group chat I
don't keep boys and then and then and then in my staff group
chat i'm gonna end guys i'm gonna fucking end and then in
our staff group chat i was like because like in like two of
my head staff members i was like hey i'm gonna self-sabotage
and implode on them because there's no staff to control me
or stop me.
Sorry, guys.
And I added them.
And then a couple, I was typing my, I was ready to all, I
was typing my messages.
I was ready.
And then one of my staff finally got, one of my staff
finally got on.
And I was like, wait, wait, what's happening?
Sorry, I'm cooking supper right now.
And I was like, look at, look at the server chat.
um okay and and she's she's trying to calm me down right now
but i'm mad i'm i'm so mad i'm i'm holding in a lot of rage
right now out all right oh man this is something i did not
want to do okay anyway deal with anyway um sorry i i oh fuck
okay i know i'm in the right too that's the worst part
sometimes in business you have to suck it up even if you
know you're in the right you have I, I, I had an
entertainment fucking good.
It's just,
yeah.
I hate that.
The truth.
All right.
So this was my day.
This was my day, guys.
Um, oh my gosh, sorry.
Dad's mad too.
Sorry.
I didn't want you guys to go through more loot.
So, um, I had to, I swapped over, so I'm still, I still have
a lot of rage in me.
Um, um, anyway, so I had to wake up at 8 a.m.
And then I was finishing up my notes for the, for the dokey
dokey rewind time concert edits, the dokey cut.
So I, I spent like, I think I wrote like, I spent like three
plus hours like writing oh my gosh why I'm mad no no sorry
like he goes and he doesn't want to stream it he always like
you did not okay anyway um I spent like three to four hours
Okay.
Sorry.
All right.
Ah!
Sorry.
Let me...
Work messages.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
I need to make sure I don't say anything to out loud while
I...
Sorry.
Alright, fuck, okay.
Alright, so.
Ah!
Okay, sorry, guys.
I've holding it in.
I've never been so mad.
I mean, I have been, but, like, usually I have time.
I have time to, like, cool down, you know, the cool down
period.
The cool down period before the stream.
But there was no time to cool down.
for anything.
Today was a really really busy day because there was so much
stuff I had to catch up on.
I can't say why I was upset.
I cannot say I just business.
Asher, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What was I say so i started eight because like i said the
right i have to finish up the notes um for uh for the doki
cut and um oh sorry i have like messages from staff trying
to calm me down and so but then at i had a two to three hour
recording session if you guys don't know What's his name?
Magic the Noah?
I don't know if you guys know his channel.
But he does these like...
I got invited to do a recording session with him.
With Chibi-Doki and Nags.
And so I think...
Yeah, so I did...
He invited me to do a game session.
A little like game that he invented.
It's wild.
It's a wild session.
It was like...
So it's me, Chibi, and Nags.
It's gonna come out.
They say I could talk about it.
I won't say like what were you It basically what he does is
that he invents these random stream games He went these
random games and then we just play it out So it was my first
time Me invited to it.
So I never did it before so it was a it was a fun it was
it's fun It was a fun session.
I don't want to spoil anything, you know I'm not gonna spoil
anything he has like for those who are like who is magic no
he has like 1.6 million followers he does does these types
of game shows with a bunch of a bunch of big creators but
just small creators like he does he does it with a lot of
people you might recognize some of the people he's collabed
with and so it was like a two to three hour recording
session so and right after that i went back to writing notes
for uh the doki cut um and um and then right after that i
went straight into uh three almost four hour work meeting uh
i got another business thing and then that was not what i
was mad about right after that i got work stuff there was a
unrelated work stuff that made me really mad and I had to
stream and like none of my staff was online at that time so
I was like mad never they even super chat they get I think
also because the meeting was almost four hours and like um
and I was just like tired and I was just like half of this
could be in an email
I was also like a lot of like half of it was important but
that was like half of it could also have been like an email
too so um it wasn't with my staff it was like another work
thing another business thing and then i was just like oh man
i'm so tired yeah so yeah i was getting a little cranky You
know, I was getting cranky and I started eating chips and
then um, I had like I have a group chat with like some of
the people in the work meeting and um, they were like, I'm
so hungry.
And I was like, I'm eating chips right now.
Because I started snacking because I didn't because like,
you know, it was a very long meeting and then I was just
snacking during the meeting.
You might be like crunch crunch while I'm eat snacking.
It was like one of the person that was in the work meeting
was like, I'm living vicariously through your chips right
now because I'm so hungry.
And I was like,
Yeah.
uh, yeah.
That, that's really it.
That was my day.
I've been working on my PC, since eight in the morning.
So I've, I'm, I'm, I'm really out of it right now.
I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm like,
wait, okay.
All right.
So, I need, I just need, I think, like, normally I wouldn't
be this mad, but I legitimately had, no chance to cool down.
And coincidentally, none of my staff was, like, online at,
that moment to be like stop because um
alright because like uh because sorry because like usually
also because I had to get a reply also because I had to
stream so I uh I like usually if I had time to process what
was going on um i could think more rationally because i'm a
very impulsive person too i'm a very impulsive person this
is why i'm glad i have staff so they could stop me when i
get impulsive
so a very impulsive person because i really i i'm very i
like to i i emotions emotions are hard I just want to go
straight in with my first my first thought Yeah I'm too
passionate I'm too fucking passionate Um Okay sorry but like
the word if I had time To uh think about what I want to say
Then like then that would have been fine because there was
no time to like I had to give a reply like soon or we lose
more time so I had to give the reply like within like 30
minutes and I was like I have a stream in 30 minutes so I so
I had to reply now but like now was the time I'm like
So, yeah, so no time to cool down.
I had no time to cool down.
I just went straight in with how I feel.
And that's why I sent warning messages to my staff.
And I was like, if something happens because of what I'm
going to say, I'm sorry.
But luckily, luckily a staff member was like, wait, wait,
stop.
Luckily, we had a staff member come in right at the right
moment before I alted.
I was like, hold me back!
Hold me back!
Yeah.
All right, anyway.
Did you guys see that new CSGO map where you can potentially
show?
to die i'm sorry i don't know i don't know what a weird
segue but i wanted to talk about something else um but there
did you did you see that you can what yeah so um csgo two i
guess i gotta strike two released a new map where you're at
like a dog shelter and um you're supposed you're trying to
it's just like the dog is uh the dog like when you're
rescuing the dog the dog is like on your shoulder and you
see it and then i was just like because my friend was
showing it to me and i was like what what happens if you
shoot the dog yeah and then he was like the dog dies and i
was like what it was just that's so yeah so it's like the
hostage map because if you shoot the The hostage dies so
he's like assuming the dog dies because it's like the same
as a hostage So I was like that's so fucked and then don't
shoot the dog but like but then you'll lose I thought that
was a good idea but let me see if I can find it Well not the
part where you shoot the dog guys not not that part but when
you're carrying the So they released a new...
I was like, who's that?
That's some sick fuck.
I'm sorry.
I will say.
Who... I want to know which dev gave the idea.
Who gave up of that idea?
That I want to know.
Who gave up the idea that you're fucking...
I don't...
That the hostages are dogs.
And then you can shoot the dog.
Whose idea was that?
That's crazy.
That's actually fucking crazy.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
Alright, so yeah, you can...
He doesn't shoot the dog here.
But this is what it looks like.
I thought it was funny, though.
Like, where he's like...
Where he was like...
Because I'm like...
I don't know.
I feel like when you're the terrorist...
goal like what they pick like how do you shoot the dog are
you gonna shoot the dog are you
are you gonna shoot the dog like is i shoot the dog or you
lose are you gonna do it taco thank you the super chat thank
you thank you jacardo thank you super chat thank you thank
you guys thank you in the super chat thank you thank you
many people are not having the remorse for shooting hostages
guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you not
clicking like they don't shoot the dog in that link guys but
you get to see the dog no you get to see like what the dog
looks like and it's like a fucking one is a golden let's go
labrador they're like labradors too that's crazy anyway uh
you're not well if you're the terrorist of you're gonna
shoot you have to shoot the dog wait do you well like you
might accidentally shoot the dog i don't think i mean you
have to but like you really gotta be able to control that
spray are you yeah anyway you lose my what the dog doing me
thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh anyway other
than that here another way was this uh all right another
thing was uh um so you guys here okay this is another thing
um is that uh do you guys know moana live action is coming
out Basically, apparently, they CGI'd the Rock's nipples off
of Maui.
Because, I don't know, I guess you're not allowed to show
nipples in movies anymore.
So, if you look at the trailer for the new Moana, for the
new Moana live-action movie, he doesn't have nipples.
Did Maui not have nipples in the animation?
Is animated nipples fine?
But like...
Oh, he doesn't!
Wait, does he?
Oh, he does!
Wait, Maui had nipples!
That's crazy.
But I thought that was...
funny yeah I mean we can't have anything anymore oh it's
very subtle they try to hide the nips like free them free
the nipple like free the nipple all
right give me a second Scott another message don't worry I'm
no longer man after thinking about Maui's non-existent
nipples.
Let's see.
All right, I wrote, I give you the power.
I stream now.
Anyway, I can't believe I missed that.
Captain America's beautiful swimsuit.
Guys, I feel like everybody talked about it, but me.
Everyone had a great time talking about it, except for me,
because I was so busy with everything else.
I'm sad.
I never got the experience pre-nerf, Captain America.
Erica's skin.
Oh, yeah.
Did I decay?
I don't... Did I decay?
Oh, I did it!
Nice.
I didn't touch Ring.
So I was just like, I don't know if I decayed or not.
Yeah, I didn't decay.
Let's go.
Alright.
Who's this?
Who's this person?
Uh...
Alright.
Give me a sec.
So, so for those who didn't know, um, I'm I could show it.
Oh, yeah, I got a little
Alright, I wrote to my staff, I give you the power I stream
now, and then my staff was like, oh, okay
Alright, give me a second, I got a little present, too, so I
might as well It's refill time Oh, I do this
What is this?
Ah, used it before you guys can use it.
It's a refill time.
Alright, so.
So, where is it?
I got it first.
That's right.
Whoa.
Let's see.
Where is Captain America?
Where is our boy?
I saw the pre-nurskine.
I thought it was DD Dynasty.
Or for a second quarter.
Thank you.
I was so afraid his swimsuit was going to get me through the
screen.
Donkey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Where is he?
Where's our boy?
Mr. America.
For those who live under the rock and didn't hear about it.
So as you.
Oh man.
All right.
So the thing about Marvel rivals and net ease is that
they're all about equality.
quality so you guys might have been like wow you know like
like wow but it used to be like this that's that's a lot of
freedom there was a lot more freedom guys oh whoa okay all
right said hi to me uh so not only did they did they nerf
this skin um it waved heavy for her to say hello guys uh but
the nerf the unprepatched skin was um a lot more intense
that's why it was pre pre-nerf and and like the i thought
the funniest part is uh is the fact that they did it on july
4th on america's birthday.
So they're like, happy birthday, America.
I'm going to take your dick.
I'm going to yoyk my dick now.
Happy birthday.
They took his freedom bells and it's insane.
the sentence no it had it you would think that it has wild
jingo physics now but you i wish we were i was able to see
it on my own screen just to compare like the because
everyone else experienced it except for me um i felt like
even people who didn't play rivals were boot read down who
stopped playing rivals or who like um who stopped playing
rivals or like uh Or never played rivals downloaded a game
just to see what's up, you know, just Just just to see what
was going on.
Anyway, happy birthday
All right, so there's a lot of I know I should check out
like every let me get some skins going on real quick What
are the new stuff?
Oh Happy birthday
All right.
Yes.
I have to switch to that.
What's going on?
There's so many things.
Oh, is this the white fox?
All right, let's pop.
Let's pop.
Pop, pop.
Purchasing through.
All right.
Do I get anything?
Yay.
Nothing.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
What am I going to do?
Happy birthday, America, Doki.
We nerfed Captain's swimsuit today.
Thank you.
Wait, what?
Jakarta.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I think it's going to take all pops.
Wait, middle.
Middle is always the way.
Yeah?
Got.
Oh!
Goddammit, guys.
Guys, it took all the pops.
It popped.
Popped it up.
Alright.
At least I got white fox first.
Yay!
Alright.
I mean, that's a good skin.
Why is that it?
Where's the Loki?
Give me my Loki now.
Oh, get it?
Yeah.
Did I get it?
Oh.
Oh, I don't think I got it.
Well, I'll pop this one.
It's all the way there.
I'll do that one.
Well, I mean, at least I'll actually use these skins.
Ooh, that's cute.
Like, I'll actually use this because, like, I play support.
Oh, fuck.
Is it the last one?
Is it the last one, guys?
It's the last one, isn't it?
Okay, wait.
Alright.
Sorry.
Alright, is either last one or second last one?
Come on!
Guys, it was the last one.
How could she do this to me?
I thought, loki-dokie.
I thought we cool.
I thought we were cool.
We're literally the same person.
I'm blonde.
You're green-haired.
Practically the same.
You could turn into a boy.
I could turn into a tomato.
We're practically sisters.
We're like...
I feel like we're almost like the same person, guys.
Almost.
Alright, Jubilee.
Shit, that's vampire Jubilee.
I guess I should...
And that's Rogue, right?
Well, Rogue's hella nerfed.
Midnight Mutant and...
Who's this guy?
What the fuck is this guy?
Okay, that's Jubilee.
I didn't try out Jubilee yet.
Yeah, apparently Jubilee's a vampire now.
Who's this one?
Who is this?
Oh, is that Wolverine?
I could not even...
Not gonna lie.
I could not tell.
I could not tell that was Jubilee.
Wolverine um I just saw okay the one thing I'm scared about
is that um I can't see shit I I noticed for uh for Jubilee
um it's a lot of clutter that's the only thing I'm concerned
about is uh the clutter does not seem um I'm not gonna buy
Wolverine there's no point that's just a
This luck is karma for the April 1st, so it's the trip.
Yeah, so apparently it's just explosives everywhere.
Fireworks.
Oh, my God.
That is very loud.
I might have to give him food.
All right, guys.
I'm going to give him food.
He's angry.
And he knows.
I'm angry, too.
But I want to be less angry.
All right.
I got him as food.
I'm back now.
Oh, yeah, he's trained me well.
All right.
Okay, so there's a lot.
So everything you know about anything is, it's over.
It's like, I don't know how to explain it.
Everything you know about everything, it's gone.
It's gone.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know.
So now you can heal with your left click.
I don't know.
But yeah, there you can tell that was what we said was
intentional.
This comment was a mystery who Apocalypse New Horseman was
like.
You need a super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it's Marvel Rivals 2 now.
So you can just heal with left click.
But it's like basically you select team ups now.
So you see like now provides healing to allies.
someone playing you can equip any of the team ups and then
do any of these things you don't need to have the characters
there to like you don't need to have the characters there uh
to to have the team up you have a list of team ups and you
just pick whatever the fuck you want yeah if you have the
character you can have an enhance enhancement of your team
up so you see here teammates teammates linked by sobon um
receives a speed boost so that's the default you don't have
to have storms there you select this team up but if you have
storm uh then link teammates also gain a damage boost so
like they're all passives now so it's it's everybody has one
it's the wild wild west now so it's the fucking wild wild
also everyone not self-heal.
Uh, not everybody, but like, it feels like everyone.
I love that.
So, I don't know if I can get through all of these for you
guys, but, like, it's just, it's the wild, like, what is
this?
What do you mean?
What, what is this?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, Everyone is, if everyone is broken, nope, no one
is, yeah, like, what are these?
You gain bonus health scaling with numbers and these struck
by slam?
Activation grants revealment, activating ability and
performs a slam and is hit by a slam or grab.
What is all of this?
Like, there's also regen green health now for some, like,
what, what, I do?
If everyone's super, no one will be.
All right, here's Black Cat.
Their damage accumulates.
Upon reaching a specific threshold, Black Cat can unleash a
violent explosion, damaging and knocking while gaining a
brief speed.
Oh, yeah, there you see the region.
Enhance the explosion no longer restricted and can be
triggered at any time.
And now there's the Spider-Man one.
replaced by spider-man grapple which has two charges landing
the i there's so many how am i oh yeah here let me show you
guys uh you know what let me just go right in i i don't know
i feel like i'm like do i go straight in and just learn in
the past like learn it live like
i just learned it live all right so i think the funniest one
is that okay sorry i need to fix here they come do i need to
fix it all right there you go all right So, you're like, oh,
Widowmaker.
Ah, yes, my sniper.
What sniper?
So, Widowmaker's not a sniper anymore, guys.
Her right click is this blast.
So, so that's her.
This is Widowmaker now.
It's a DMR.
What sniper?
No.
So, you want to like, but how does she...
How does she snipe, though?
That's a good question.
So you see how I have my...
Perfect.
Precision.
That...
I don't even one-shot.
I don't even one-
It's not even a one-shot.
Like, yeah, you bro.
So, this is Widowmaker now.
And class in...
Class in session.
What is...
that yeah so even for squishies she doesn't she doesn't
really one-shot anymore uh but you can collect though you're
right you can collect you can see watch this that's the neat
part you don't so even you know you could get them all close
to one who you collect um so yeah that's uh
So, that's basically it.
Alright.
There's so...
I don't know, guys.
There's...
Oh, yeah, so this is the team up.
So you can select which team up you want.
There's guys.
I'm just gonna...
Should I just like...
Should I just encounter it live?
Oh, yeah.
I heard about...
Okay.
Regeneration provides a damage boost effect to allies
moving...
Oh, yeah.
I remember that.
When Tina emits a shockwave of nature energy that...
damages enemies within the radius and slightly launches them
up excuse me what how do i
wait how do i do this what is this team up i don't
understand all right where's my team up okay it provides a
damage boost effect the arena triggers a site expanding the
domain oh i need the team up okay i forgot well give me my
mantis where are my mantises my mantises all right it has to
be this all right all right let's all right what is this
like what is that all right all right all right i feel like
the hella one is the most broken though isn't it isn't the
hella one more broken what is the hella one gain new ability
target fallen enemies letting ooki assume their form for a
set time when team up with loki's transformation last
slightly left for him we're taking lethal damage while
transforming will merely reverse oh yeah no that is stronger
wait where's hella all right Can I clone here?
No, I have to clone here.
Wait, it's this one, right?
Alright.
Oh.
That.
Wait.
Oh, so everyone I kill.
I can transform.
Oh.
It's a mini.
alt but i can't use your alt yeah but i can't use your alt
but i can like i guess be an extra dps i don't know actually
i feel like mantis this one would be the mantis one would be
better honestly oh i can step oh yeah my tank is down i
could step in i think i maybe it's like more strategic and
what you have to do so it's more like strategic wise all
right jubilee it's time to learn I heard she was bad so
maybe I don't have to learn oh my god all right okay guys
it's another essay it's every new character they release I
feel like it's an it's I have to get another PhD
every time all right let me see all right let's see when the
okay all right uh who's this guy fire explosive light blast
forward to heal friends and that triggering a sparkle mark
briefly boost attacks we enables firing without consuming
energy i haven't oh wait that must be my uh jubilee charge
up and unleash a massive ring of outward flying firework
clusters launching up nearby enemies these clusters then
orbit you creating a field that damage enemies and heals
allies expanding cluster outward will launch struck and
Jesus Christ.
Wrap yourself in vampiric energy.
Please stop snapping Jubilee.
I'm trying to read right now.
Wrapping yourself in vampire.
Oh, she's four stars.
Wrapping yourself in vampiric energy.
The game of speed boost.
While active, jump height and attack speed.
And then you can fire upon general fire.
Okay.
Then you have firework dealing damage to enemy.
And they're applying.
Energy can also be transferred to an energy.
Launch a tracking orb of vampiric energy.
damages enemy and heals allies striking the orb or hitting
targets near it charges us up increasing both its size press
f what the okay hitting target dazzling and applies a energy
can quickly grounding while dealing all right look i have i
have i understand all right um what was this again oh does i
can night wait what okay i can if i can use this to heal
right yeah i can use this to heal okay and then all right
and then what am i doing
and what do these do again
okay let's see let me uh oh i can shoot the How do I shoot
it?
How do I shoot it?
What am I...
Oh, I can make it bigger!
It's so big now!
Oh my god!
Alright.
Adjust angle.
What am I adjusting?
Oh!
No, this is a lot.
The radius.
Alright, I get it.
I get it.
She did not get it.
Hey guys, I get it.
I get it.
I definitely get it, guys.
I just need to figure it out.
What is E though?
What is...
Wait, what the fuck is E?
Uh, ding that is...
Oh, I did...
Oh!
Okay, so if I put this in, and then...
That's what it does.
Oh, I see.
Okay, I figured it out.
Wait, what's my C again?
What's my C?
Guys, I'm not gonna be playing here anyway.
What am I doing?
Okay, it's life's here.
I'm just thinking like, what am I doing?
I'm not even gonna be playing here.
Like, what the fuck am I doing?
What am I doing here?
What am I?
We're not even gonna be playing.
Alright, let's see our new stuff.
Boy, Fox received an orb of life from black cat pond use it
recovers and converts life energy that shoots out the armor
jesus christ okay granting speed and healing activating no
longer consumes and grants the maximum oh wait that's wait
that's that's good wait i don't have to worry about the the
spirit tail shit wait that seems broken okay we're not
playing well i heard gabit is instaband because of how
strong he is right now.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, Luna with White Fox.
All right, what is it?
Unleash a Spear Fox forward that charms...
Okay, we know that.
And cleanse all negative side effects on...
Okay, I didn't realize that one, though.
When T-M will be White Fox, the Spear Fox automatic returns
after reaching its maximum distance and the self-cleanse is
retained.
Oh, shit, what?
Oh, shit, it goes back.
back and forth yeah CC immune yeah it's yeah and a self
cleanse is retained
all right then who cares about soul bound wait reduces the
cooldown absolute zero okay nobody cares about that okay I
know this one was broken with Luna I heard everyone talking
about that while frozen becomes significant this is
basically a May ice block for those who haven't seen it so
yeah
So I can basically turn into a May...
It's based on May Ice Block.
But the Enhanced Team Up is...
The Enhanced Team Up makes it so that...
So that my allies also healed.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it...
Wait, does it do damage?
I was...
Yeah, you can heal.
I named it Smuik Healing Ora.
But Enhanced, it says...
The Healing Ora becomes stronger.
Yeah, I heard you can avoid a lot of ults with who cares
about the other stuff with the hood like I honestly Yeah,
that's entire essay.
I'm not reading that.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm not reading that That's a fucking essay.
It's fine All right, what's this recasting healing flower
and teammate with effect and spreads the healing aura any
insulin triggers and have spell field and healing effect.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay.
Nothing heals the soul like a bit of gardening.
So is it, like, stronger?
Like, is it makes it...
Yeah, oh, it's AoE.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I see it, yeah.
It's AoE healing.
Alright, and then Inslee triggers Hand spell filled And
healing error Oh my god, there's so much Jakarta, thank you,
thank you, thank you Upon defeat, Madness can freely move as
a soul Healing nearby allies and reinforce your body I chose
in this spot after using Oh wait, no, this would be better
Like I could be dead and I could still heal you
Damage taking across the bond I can literally like Die for
you You can't kill someone that's already dead.
Wouldn't this one be better?
Because I can literally, like, even when dead, I can still,
like, just hover around you.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Wait, no, this shit is broken.
All right, kill me.
I need to see this.
Wait, is Starlord team up better?
It's busted?
Like, look at me, go!
Don't worry.
I'm...
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, never mind.
It's a lot shorter than I expected.
I don't know why I thought I'd be floating for like 20
years.
Never mind.
That was fast.
I didn't realize I'd die that.
I'd disappear that fast.
All right.
Convert bombard mode to launch thorny spawns.
Upon impact, it deals to news damage to enemies and
granting.
When tail group rocket can ride and then active is...
Extended.
What's this?
Bombardment!
Oh, this is dumb.
This is dumb.
I mean, I guess.
What's the squirrel girl?
Toss a scattered batch of augmented vitality acorns that hit
the floor.
Hit me.
I thought it would, like, stick on the floor.
Not gonna lie.
Litter struck directly or picked up teammates to receive a
burst of healing and global cooldown.
Max and Trash for this ability is increased.
What the fuck?
Or just pick it up?
Alright.
I'll just be like, eat this, guys!
It's like a Jeff bubble.
Wait, how long do they stay there?
Are they there forever?
Oh, shit, yeah!
Okay, this is not as bad.
This one is actually pretty good.
Yeah, there's cooldown reduction.
I'd be like, it's feeding time!
Dinner's up, it's time to chow down!
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's like an armor.
Oh, it is!
It's like an armor pack, but better.
Because this has...
I can actually...
I can actually lag a server with this.
Ha ha ha ha!
Go nuts.
And I can lag a server.
How many nuts can I put?
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
That's as many nuts I can put.
What about?
What are you guys?
Does anyone know?
I know the game just came out today.
But does anyone know what's meta?
Does anyone know?
Oh, this one.
I thought this one was crazy.
Generate a flame shield.
Projectiles.
What's the?
When team up with a human torch.
Boost a larger radius and heavily shield.
Okay, how?
How?
All right.
You haven't seen this.
You can make Jeff blow out like fire spit All right, where
is it?
So you can make a fire shield like this So Everything is
like enhanced and then Let's see where is all right torch
come over here How bigger?
We've got trouble Bro, that's the fucking island What the
fuck?
I can guard an entire country with the shield.
Oh my god.
I can guard an entire fucking country.
My tail and Mr. Healing Invisible.
Oh yeah, this is where I can make everybody invisible.
I feel like the torch one is better, isn't it?
Yeah, I was like, disappear!
Oh, he's still dead.
It's not too long, though.
I feel like the Torch one is a better team up versus...
Uh...
Versus all the other ones.
Alright, Ultron, what do you have?
Upgrade.
Fire multiple damaging nano projectiles forward.
When TNT out with Iron Man.
Fires powerful homing missiles.
Who the fucking cares about homing missiles?
Pennyfire firewall applies to all drones allowing the
ability to affect...
Oh, what?
To all allies?
Wait, excuse me?
Did I say all allies?
Oh, what's the cooldown?
What's the cooldown?
Oh, 15 seconds.
Okay, that's nice.
Yeah, but I can do it anywhere I want on the map, too.
Yeah, so I can do this.
Yep, you did not miss.
I just wanted to be sure.
I was like, Excuse me, all?
All right, Gambit.
I'll look at it just for fun.
Even though I know you're just an Instaban.
All right, let's see.
Throw two Magnetic Playing Cards four upon hitting the
environment.
The two cards Magnetically repel enough for all spinning in
place.
Where the heal allies, they hit.
Well, what's the point?
I'm just going to be Instaban anyway.
All right, let's go in, Raw.
Let's just go in.
Fuck it.
Look at this.
Who cares?
I think I've heard enough.
He said he wanted to play.
I'm ready.
Alright, let's go in.
I'm gonna learn.
I'm gonna get yelled at.
I'm ready to get yelled at, guys.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to not know what the fuck I'm doing.
And I'm gonna be like seeing everybody do like crazy shit.
And I was just like, what the...
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna see everybody do the wildest shit.
And like seeing all these new team ups and everything.
And I'm like...
I was like, when did he...
When was he able to do that?
I'd be like, oh shit.
I've read all of them, I guess.
I guess I should have read all the T-moves.
Alright, what can he do?
But Mr. Maximum's last is increased and he can actively
enter inflation state.
Nice.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
We're gonna figure it out as we go along.
3 DPS.
Let's go.
Alright.
All right, let's see what's her team up.
Oh, I guess I guess I can't see it.
Yes, I can't see it.
All right, guys, what goes well with Mantis?
I'm going to get, like, I'm going to get fucked up.
I don't know what any of the team ups with DPS and Tank just
absorbed everything for support.
And every, my survival is too, baby.
I don't even know what people bad.
I think what can you bad like like everything is bannable
now like
I'm ready I'm ready Everything I learned doesn't matter
anymore.
Fuck you.
We ball Marvel Raffles too.
Let's go Where can I play with this your rocket?
I don't, what do I, uh, rocket?
And I'll give you peanuts.
There you go.
I'll give you the rocket.
There we go, guys.
I'll give you some fucking nuts, I guess.
Wait, is rocket nerfed?
Oh, no.
I'm feeling a little squib.
I thought I just wanted to give him the nuts.
30 seconds before you okay it's just as up guys it's it's
fine it's gonna be fine it's gonna be so fine this we're
learning it live don't worry guys got my nuts
it's okay that's true but i don't want to i don't want to
aim on my first game
That's true.
But that requires me to aim on my first game.
That is...
Whoops.
Don't worry, guys.
I got nuts.
I have a window.
Don't worry, I have nuts!
Oh, shit.
Grab my nuts!
Felix Yes, there's so many nuts just grab them
What's the point of throwing nuts if nobody takes my nuts?
Look at that.
Oh my god the heal everybody can heal now I forgot When
we're all super no one is nuts i don't have any cooldowns
there we go look at that look at them go just keep nutting
don't worry guys i have nuts in three nuts in three guys
nice all right there you go Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Oh, that's awkward for me.
No,
no, no.
No, Jokey, please.
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm healing us.
Oh, my God, guys.
The widow's doing it.
It's okay.
I'll put this here for now.
Oh my god!
You guys are down.
Eat up!
Are you all hungry?
You guys are sped up.
Who's hungry?
Who's hungry right now?
Alright.
Oh shit, that's good.
That's a good ult.
Good ult.
Deadpool 1?
Oh, Deadpool God?
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll throw some nuts on the side.
With the charcuterie board.
It's okay.
I have ult soon.
I feel like my ult takes a long time to build.
I will say.
Don't worry!
Oh, maybe you worry?
Oh?
Did you?
Hey guys, there is somebody on point.
There you go!
What is he gonna do?
Oh shit.
It's alright, we're all alive, right?
He might not be able to get reached out here.
Hey guys, there's a...
Oh my no!
poop nuts still someone take them i pooped some nuts on the
floor
don't worry she dropped her nuts don't worry guys i'm
contributing to this team her nuts drop
All right, I do feel the all charge is definitely heavily,
heavily nerfed
Oh, drop think of that stick to that.
Oh, nice
Nuts There's nuts over it.
Take it
Do not eat those nuts.
Okay.
I don't know how to feel.
This game, I will say, rank feels a lot more casual.
Did they change the voice lines on some of the characters?
They sound so bad.
That was nuts.
I don't have a sin.
I wanted to iron it.
I think the community actually wanted the...
When everybody's super, no one is.
The white fox's alt was like, it sounded good.
I feel like this feels I do not I feel like I'm playing
quick play I really this game feels much more casual like
low-key this feels really casual I do not feel like I'm
playing a competitive game I legit don't feel like I'm
playing a better game.
Nobody, that's true.
Nobody knows what's going on.
I'm just throwing nuts down and praying for the best.
Don't worry.
Oh, she has damage boost.
That's illegal.
Do not worry.
I'm here.
Nuts!
You guys around?
Eat it!
It's so yum yum yum!
I'm contributing!
See, this is why I played this as my first game.
Oh look, see, she's frozen now.
I'm gonna destroy this real quick.
Okay, yum yum.
This year.
My wing win.
Oh yeah, I heard Black Ops 2 is back.
on PlayStation.
There's a lot of gamers there.
Oh.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Well, that, I, well, all right.
You guys go do your thing.
That's coming in at five.
Whoa.
What are you doing?
Wow.
You crazy.
You are madman.
He's still doing it!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, we're fine.
No way!
This is nuts!
I just gave her, I fed her all my nuts, guys.
Like, I didn't realize you could just do that.
You could just chuck all the nuts you have in your
inventory.
Okay, this is a little bad for me.
Nuts!
Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
It's just shocking my...
Like, all of my nuts and semantics.
I'm back.
Back to doing my job.
No, Rockets, Alt definitely got nerfed hard.
I think they're going to go towards the Black Manus.
Because, like, because I'm taking fucking forever to build
an Alt right now, and I'm just chucking heels.
I feel like I'm doing my job.
There you go.
It's fine.
Perfect precision.
Oh, shit.
What are they gonna do, huh?
Kill us?
But what if... Oh, my god.
It's okay.
Get in here!
Eat the nuts!
Keep eating, guys!
Oh, shit!
Oh, God, God, there's more.
There we go.
We work together.
We had this.
There's a team effort.
I don't know.
I don't know what was going on.
I don't know what's going on, guys.
Is that good, huh?
No.
It's all right.
Eat it.
Take it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's okay.
Eat him!
Oh, shit.
Where the fuck?
There's a mantis.
Oh, there's a widow behind us.
Oh, wait.
They used...
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Eat him!
Oh, this is bad for me.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Our support... Our mantis is coming in, hot!
Don't worry, I have an idea.
I did it!
Wait, that's so smart.
I go Ultron and I do all heals.
And then that gives everybody heals.
Oh, I'm theory crafting.
I'm actually theory crafted in the fucking break of the
game.
I did it.
I had the idea.
I didn't utilize it, but it was there.
It's the thought that counts.
Oh my god.
Ultron I swapped to Ultron and then give everybody heals
Creating the new strat write that down The revolutionary
tech Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Watch it get nerfed.
There was an idea That's all that counts What you said this
is GM you better call it nuts and bolts papa smirth thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you six games off top
500 technically what the fuck what is top 500 dude you're
top 500 oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god um he's six
games off top 500 i'm so happy for you i'm so hold up i came
in here and chat one time do it with you and mvp'd and you
went negative what was this two seasons back you went like
double neck i went hello
damn um same name it is now trebo where the fuck is trebo i
don't know the hero members trebo i don't know you know my
name i'm not gonna play rocket can we ban it if we're not
gonna rocket can we get any are we playing rocket external
three two three two what oh what was it good then it did we
bad that is ass hey man bob bro it's broken what do you
think what do i play good aim it's good i have good aim at
bronx that is not that she looks like this oh wait wait wait
oh What do you mean?
Devil dinosaurs broken.
One life on Hulk.
What if I go?
What if I go Adam?
I don't think I don't know if Adam works.
Me?
No, Mantis got bad.
Oh, I should play that.
Hold on.
Wait, where is it?
I should do that.
Wait, Super.
Wait, what's the same?
I was looking me around.
Super Gomez.
Could you go Hulk?
Oh, I don't know.
Play that.
You can't play Hulk?
Oh, dude.
I'll play High Elo.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you're High Elo.
Damn, you're High Elo.
Aren't you?
There's a super flexible play.
Every single part of the game.
We are in top.
Aren't you top by fun though?
No.
Come on, bro.
Top of a meal.
Guys, I'm gonna be so confused on Jubilee.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna like explode.
I'm gonna explode.
Okay, one life on hold.
Okay, one life.
Just one.
One life.
Okay, I'm not gonna do this.
And I'm not throwing anybody.
Yeah, and everybody's life will win.
This Hulk is good.
One life.
One life on hold.
One life, guys.
I don't remember how to do this.
It's been a while.
Alright guys!
Oh, I...
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Whoa!
Whoa, guys!
That's a lot of damage right now, and I don't know if I like
that.
That's a...
That was a lot of damage.
Oh my god, what game am I playing right now?
When everyone is super, no one is.
Actually, like, we're alive.
Good for us.
Oh, I'm going to make sure I don't waste that.
I'm gonna burst in three, two, one.
Oh my god.
I don't have shields anymore.
They got fast bullets.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's okay.
It's okay.
We're all alive.
Here, use my shield!
What the fuck?
There you go.
Back up.
Over here.
All right, there you go.
Syndrome was right.
There's so many colors on my screen.
There's so many colors on my screen, guys.
I don't know what I'm...
I don't know what I'm looking at.
There's greens, there's blues.
I have an orange shield.
I...
What am I...
What's going on?
Where are these colors coming from?
Oh, okay.
Alright, that is 10.
You see that?
Guys, we're so close to top 500.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Give me over here.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh my I'm kidnapped him.
I kidnapped him.
Alright, there you go.
We're chilling.
We're chilling right now.
It's okay.
It's like me and Luna's got the damage boost!
Greens, blues, yellows, fire!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh, like, what do the colors mean?
What do they mean?
I'll hit it with your ult.
In there, Hulk.
What do these colors mean?
I can catch a counter.
My bad, guys.
I missed.
Welcome to rivals right now.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him, wait,
hold on, he's portaling.
Wait, they're actually portaling, for real.
Oh my god, I fucking...
Guys, I'm dead, guys.
Guys, we're...
Oh no, wait, where's our portal?
Where's our portal?
TP now
Oh shit Oh fuck I'm dead Top 500 Wait can can we touch The
king
says no small
It's okay.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy right now.
We might have thrown a little bit, but we're so healthy.
Okay, I need to save my...
I need to save my push.
Here we go.
There we go.
Top 500.
This team up is like extra harder than me because I'm always
shooting.
Alright.
What was that portal?
What the fuck was that portal?
Three, two, one.
Is everyone?
Where is everybody?
Oh, that is everybody.
That is.
Look at that.
Use the shield.
I bet.
That's right.
Two out of two.
Use that damage.
Ah, that's horrible.
There you go.
Wait, this game is getting a little hard now.
You have to smash all the ult though.
Like, I'm getting it.
I'm already at 30.
There you go.
Yay!
Don't worry.
Chill.
Oh, I'm gonna back out a little bit
Oh, is everybody okay there?
Is there?
He doesn't know where I am.
He knows where I am He doesn't know where I am and then he
figured it out They used three up Bro, I don't I don't know
what's going on.
This is a This feels too good to be true.
I can't wait for me to lose absolutely horribly on the next
game.
This is going too good to be true right now.
Oh, shit.
All right.
I'm battling for this ace.
It's all right.
What is he gonna do?
We have fire!
What you gonna do about fire?
Venom!
Get out of here!
I don't...
The great push.
He's not gonna kill me, right?
Yeah, it's five.
Oh shit!
Guys, we're doing it again guys
It's okay In their time who is better Gomez or Tia like
which super
It's okay.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy
It's okay.
It's not a top 500, but all right look at that.
I'm gonna say yeah used to be back there we go look at that
this is a true top 500 right there this is top 500.
did you guys know this is a top 500 lobby did you guys guys
know yeah that's the top 500 why are you a team of merchant
in the game that just became a non-team-up merchant game
what do you mean wait why do you need the whole team up if
this was a top 500 lobby and you shouldn't be reliant on
this top 500 players like to use their resources properly
which one is that oh let's jump back to the most optimal way
to wear would use it with limited resources as a top 500
player i could tell you that those top 500 players like to
use their resources
and then instead you want your little you want your little
baby food spread into your mouth
Spooky like a true top 500 player, that's all I can say.
That's a top 500 player.
You need that player, don't you?
This is the time where you go dinosaur and then you stop
giving this guy the team up, right?
You're right.
You can just form without it.
Um, eventually you're the top 500 player.
What are you talking about?
We're talking about top 500.
I want to be a dinosaur because he's cool.
Exactly.
Now this is a real top 500 lobby.
Now it's the top 500 lobby.
Let's go!
I'm healing!
Wait, they're dumb.
They just used their squid already.
They have no gamma squid.
Guys!
I'm healing!
Now I can really dive them.
I don't know if this is a good idea or not.
Guys, I'm hit!
Whoa!
It's okay.
I don't need healing, though.
Boom!
I didn't even realize he was there.
Is that why your steps were getting top five conversation?
Coming up, three, two, one.
He didn't have portal.
I can't.
They didn't get through you.
Look at that.
Good portal.
Oh my god, that's top 500 void right here.
Oh, that's a good portal.
Oh, that is a good portal.
Don't worry.
Let's go.
Let's go in.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, my.
Top 500 place, guys.
Guys, good job.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
Top 500.
A top 500 out of 500 right there.
There's a very top 500 player.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
That felt like a top 500 game right there, guys.
Nice top 500 Adam Tokeyford.
Yeah, so it's 2.
Team up, his team up now gives me heals now.
Look at that, guys.
We did not, well, they don't even know how much they heal.
Wait, how do we know how much tank heals, anyway?
The tanks have their own heal stats.
By God, I hope not.
I hope they don't.
Because tanks can self-heal, so I'm, like, curious.
Do they have their own, like...
They have their, like, heal stat i cannot believe yo can i
get a hulk oh no it's over oh no i don't want to play in
this top 500 lobby anymore can i get a hulk we run you want
me that you want me the first time hulk in top 500 thank you
toky for showing me what top 500 looks like it's my don't
worry nope my pleasure guys my i know i know this is the
experience the top 500 experience yeah yo don't ban gamut
i'm gonna play gamut all right top 500 players are
consistent all right
what if what if they ban it though
sure they're not top 500 so they're not gonna ban it bro no
no we're all top 500.
no i'm saying they they aren't so they're not gonna oh
that's rude by
the way what's the better team up for hulk the wolf one the
wolf one okay oh wait isn't the slam one kind of op you got
shields from it no it's way too long of a cooldown oh is it
like 20 seconds yeah sorry
work messages you'll need a top-notch team to win oh my god
why do I even play with gamut I'm gonna snow like the moon
I'm going the suit darkness I guess Luna
Wait, yeah, this thing is opiates balls.
Why would I never use this?
Ah, sorry.
My word message makes me mad.
Scylac needs to get the, what's it called thing,
regenerative taken away, in my opinion.
Wait, what?
Makes no sense.
The regenerative shield on Scylac just makes no sense.
She has a regen shield now?
Oh, hell no.
lives long enough he gets the shield too isn't the emma team
up just more broken though oh yeah that one's good yeah it's
good because you don't need emma for it mainly oh my god
okay sorry mad what oh that's a bad oh no i gotta go down
get him in just give him oh no I hear I hear it yeah where's
my spider-man where's my spider-man right now where's my
spider-man What?
Ranging.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
No longer.
No longer cancel.
No more cancel.
Where the fuck are you?
Look at my spider-man!
There he is!
Yo.
Why is he not me?
I think they're saving it for later.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Good, good top five on the place, buddy.
Oh, God, I hear him.
Oh, awesome.
Why am I dead?
Those are all gonna be.
Oh!
Top five on the next one.
Oh, he is so low!
oh it's fine we have self-heal so it's been so long since I
played Luna guys please please have mercy it's been so long
since I played okay it's okay I don't know where I spot him
at spot him at please oh god what's going on no shit there's
So many colors!
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Here's Spider-Man.
Take this.
All right.
Oh my god, Ali.
Take the Spider-Man.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
Take this Spider-Man!
All right.
Okay, I'm still alive.
What is going on over there?
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit.
What?
Where did he go?
Let's chase the daredevil for like two minutes.
He's not on an assist.
Oh, that's unlucky for me.
Actually, that's insane.
The one time I'm not focusing in, he kills my support.
Oh, yeah.
So little, dude.
Fuck me, I guess.
I think it's fine.
We don't need to do shit, honestly.
Let's keep going.
I don't have to use anything yet.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's bad.
That's bad.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize he was going to throw me.
Oh god!
Oh!
I should have upped it!
There's too many colors!
Oh shit, I fell off the sky!
I hate to get that!
What's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
On my screen!
I...
It's actually so hard for me right now.
Just gotta chill out.
Oh, fuck it, let's go.
That's fine.
Is everybody okay?
What's going on?
Oh, no.
Cleanse!
Oh, we tried.
We tried so hard to protect you.
Do it, do it, do it.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad for me.
Oh, that's bad.
I want to.
That's fucking cool.
There is...
I don't...
Okay.
There you go.
That's a good freeze.
It doesn't do anything, but that's a good freeze.
freeze oh god oh god oh my god what I want them what okay
I'm coming back all right I might have to swap guys this is
This is too much.
I got bursted so high.
Hey guys, why don't we like stand on here?
You know?
I'm just gonna stand here for now.
And then I'll put that over there.
And maybe I'll hit somebody.
Oh, this is bad for us though.
I have to reload.
I am ready to put on a show.
I got hug!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
I need reload.
I must have another gambit.
Okay.
What am I looking at?
Oh, this is bad for me.
This is so bad for me.
This is...
What am I looking at?
It's okay.
Who cares about me?
It's alright.
Just live.
No one cares about me.
I'm just a... I'm just a Korean K-pop star.
My life doesn't matter.
You got my one-on.
Someone, please kill him.
Someone, please.
Please, I might not.
Please.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God!
Don't die everything!
I just got CC'd for 80 seconds!
I just got CCed.
I got CCed for 80 seconds.
I know.
It's just like the top 500 plays of just being able to be
top 500.
Oh my god.
Top 500.
I'm not going to top 500 and swap the mag though.
I still lose.
What the hell's wrong with you?
It was a timeout.
Scarlet now.
He needs his team.
Scarlet.
I could do that I'm surprised me too I need skies give me I
need time yeah I give me a sec guys I need random I need
time I need time to fucking process what happened to me I'm
going I'm going way faster yeah I need I Is the stop by
legend?
I don't know.
So I don't think of the super chat thing.
I need time.
The process will just happen to me.
Wait a minute.
I thought the clone thing was OP.
No, the other one gives you wall hacks and grounding.
What was my thing again?
I didn't even.
What is my team?
Oh wait, I have unlimited.
Wall hacks.
Is that it?
Wall hacks and grounding.
Yeah, and it gives you an extra dive.
All right.
Oh, I see.
Stop 500 processing right now.
Maybe I should have kept it on the Spider-Man.
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
Guys, it was really rough for me.
That's fine.
We're so fine.
I don't know.
There we go.
I don't know what's going on.
on still all
right things are happening it feels a little easier I'm so
healthy the colors what do the colors mean what do the
colors mean watch out spider-man coming behind i saw all
these going behind right now i'm i'm so paranoid right now
oh no no that's right get out of here i don't i didn't do it
correctly but get out of here i technically didn't even do
the anti-dive correctly though i just i just Shrek my claws
out in open air and be like, that's right, you scared,
aren't you?
I bet you're so scared.
You're so scared right now.
Yo, I'm scared right now.
Oh my god, get myself out of here.
It was.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What?
What's going on?
She's gone yet.
Oh my god!
What's going on?
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Ah, shit!
Okay, that was on me.
That was on me.
There's too many things on my screen.
I, I, I, that was my, that was me, that was me.
That, that was me.
That was, that was me.
Wee.
Okay.
One thing.
Like, I take those.
I am ready to put on a shot.
All right.
That's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's
fine, I'm done with more.
I'm done.
All right, yeah.
See, everything is fine.
Okay, okay, I'm out of distance.
There's a top 500 DD behind us.
Need my top 500 energy litigator?
bubble that was a good ass bubble that was a top 500 bubble
oh shit no don't worry i'll scratch i got her i got him i
was like i'll scratch him don't worry oh my god well well
that's you know That's fine.
That is fine.
I kept their supports kind of busy.
You guys kill them, right?
Wait, he has up.
Oh shit, I should have portals.
JK, my bad.
My bad.
Wait!
Oh shit, I was gonna do it.
Guys.
I'm helping.
It's fine.
I...
It's alright.
I helped.
Guys.
Look at that.
Ultron was dead.
We got the dub.
I'm so confused.
This is actually a town 500 lobby.
I thought it was bottom 500 when I first joined I think it
was super chat stuck.
Thank you.
Oh, I was gonna see if we could check it
Did we get them?
We didn't get them this time This time unfortunately they
are not back It's yeah it's both it's technically both I
don't want to Trimantus out.
Which one was good?
Was it the Star...
The Starlord one was really good, right?
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
Alright.
Here we go.
Is Cloak and Dagger this season crazy?
I don't know, guys.
Everything's crazy.
Yes.
It feels like everything is...
Is I I don't know what's going on guys
Can't just be like I don't know you're like yeah, that's
crazy I'm like you think that's crazy I I don't know what's
going on
Everyone's everyone's going sicko mode right now and I'm
like I don't know I
I feel like I'm drowning and I need someone to fucking send
me a life rack.
Thank God this game is third person.
Thank fucking God.
To be fair, very few other people know what's going on.
I'm going to try and get, I actually get out of silver mines
myself.
MVS, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's been a wild ride.
Nothing heals the soul like a bit of gardening.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Alright, let's try.
I sense great sadness.
Let's try Mantis.
I don't know.
What can you ban?
What can you even ban?
What the...
What do I ban?
The battle starts in 5.
4, 3, 2, All you need to do is capture the mission.
All right, here we go.
Bad everyone.
That's the secret.
Bad the whole roster.
Guys, I feel like we definitely don't have enough bands now.
We might need more bands.
Is that crazy?
We're at this point where we actually might need more bands.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Every, oh my god.
Everything, it's...
We're back at it.
We're back at it, guys.
There's too many colors again.
I think it'll be fine, right?
We're at this point Where I'm just I don't know There's too
many colors God
Oh my god it's fine I'll be on here Too many colors
I'm trying to shoot at them But like where's like my team
Where's the enemy team Where
where are they it's giant where are they it's okay it's okay
everything's fine oh my god i fell down it's okay
everything's fine she could copy
okay you'll need my oh shit dono dono dono Oh, shit.
Copy me.
This is the only way.
I think I slept somebody.
There we go.
All right, there we go.
Guys, I'm building my first ult right now.
I'm building my first ult, dude.
I don't think I... All right, just in case.
Just in the case.
Just in case.
Alright, don't worry.
Go kill him!
That's right!
Yum, yum, yum!
Oh my gosh.
The colors.
What did they mean?
A G2.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do not.
Do not, guys.
Do not look at me.
My damage.
Team up his actual dog ass.
You're not looking for damage, guys.
That's my three levels.
Guys, turn around.
Turn around.
Look away.
Also, does the die go turds do anything?
There's so many colors you don't understand.
There's so many colors.
Look away.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for shaking me.
Thank you.
Stop showing us.
Stop, look away!
Stop, I was with Tamish Quill.
Thank you.
Guys, stop me!
It's not me!
It's so much!
I don't understand!
I can't see!
Look away!
Stop!
Stop looking!
I need you guys to stop looking!
Alright.
Alright, this...
Look!
I'm shooting!
I swear!
Oh shit, okay.
Well I hope everybody else would be okay.
Oh shit, oh I did not see you.
My bad.
Go away, I threw it!
What the fuck who's over there?
Oh that's our venom.
Again!
Oh, whoops.
Oh.
Don't worry Guys the only reason my damage is like that's
because they surrendered early guys It's because they
surrender early.
I could have totally find more.
I could've.
Guys look at my Loki guys.
Look at my Loki Don't look at the enemy supports look at my
Loki and I look at
Like see look at look at like, guys look me and Loki we're
the same Sure.
Sure.
Whatever you say.
Guys, guys, trusty sidekick, by the way.
I think we're in top 500 ELNO.
I genuinely.
Wait.
Stop.
Cute.
I want to see.
Wait, I want to see it.
Wait, I want to see it for real.
Let's see it.
There's no way.
That's actually so...
Wait.
There's no way.
Wait, I think if I...
There's that spruce.
We...
I'm actually top 500.
I'm actually top 500 right now.
Wait a minute.
I can't...
It's because I'm still doing placements.
So I'm still doing placements.
So it doesn't tell me I'm top 500.
Easiest top 500 of my life, guys.
Congrats.
It's just that easy.
Okay, cute.
Look at that.
The top 500 real, not fake.
Top 500 in placements.
This is where it goes downhill.
This is where I actually start getting yelled at.
I'm pretty sure.
Right here.
Alright.
I want to track the...
Oh shit, woman wants cloak and dagger.
Oh.
We should give woman...
minute cloak and dagger
I don't know I just haven't played cloak yet I just wanted
to play let's finish placements oh we can do wait
let me see
oh my god work message uh
Alright.
Doki Engi.
When am I not Engi though?
Which one will I try?
I want to do...
I'll ever play Cloak because I don't play Invis.
Here.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Go cloak!
Come on!
You know you want to do it.
Come on, woman.
Alright, let's see.
Woman doesn't want to...
Ah, clip.
Fine.
Wait.
That's fine.
Woman doesn't want to play...
I don't know if he wants to play rocket to like grab our
maybe it's for the armor maybe I think it's the armor maybe
he's gonna swap I say like her name is her name is woman how
else am I supposed to say woman all right let's try this out
I'm gonna play who was that
Oh shit, there's Jubilee.
Oh, we can walk him down.
Good trick.
Who did we kill?
That happened so fast.
There were so many things on my screen as always.
There's always so many things on my screen.
Oh shit.
Unlucky.
Oh.
Oh my god.
There's too many things going on right now.
There's, oh my god.
I'm just trying to make sure everybody's okay.
Jesus Christ, everybody.
Ah, flip, flip, oh.
What the fuck?
I'm so dead.
Hello, everybody.
Run!
Hello.
I'm okay.
Guys, this might be the game.
This might be the one game we lose.
I think there is a chance that maybe...
When I say walk up, just pull from the back up.
So I have a bunch of mines in the back line.
This might be the game.
This might be it.
I'm really scared about ulting right now.
That's how fuck it's going on.
What is going on?
Guys, I'm tempted to swap.
I think I might swap.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't think this is it.
Guys.
Guys, I think this team...
I'm trying to believe.
I really am You have to walk There's two of them on me And
they're fun I really am trying to believe God
Oh shit There you go Oh shit Oh my god What's going on Okay
Okay all right that's five we don't have to waste this yet
we have to waste this now we have to waste it okay I don't
know about that though I don't know about that though what's
going on I don't know if I should say this.
Did my rocket just let me die because they AFK'd all...
Oh, I had to pause something.
I'm sorry.
We're chilling.
How are you dying?
They're all dead.
Damn!
How are you dying?
Yeah, how are you dying, bro?
Not like dead.
Walking down.
Focus, should we in the back?
I don't like debating.
I should.
All right.
We should live through that, right?
Say it a little, papa.
The home I made for everyone.
But I made a home for everyone.
Good shit.
Yo, Gomez, you...
You play Rainbow?
oh but my teammate normal she sounded so disappointed oh
never mind you're not that important that's crazy god damn
oh never mind Never mind, I guess.
Sorry, buddy.
You ain't some...
You ain't anyone.
Oh, my god.
No, that guy's not living.
That guy's not living.
That guy.
Oh.
I died for myself.
I...
He looked at me, okay?
He looked at me very scary.
I got scared.
I'm making the back up.
Look, it was very scary.
Oh, that's bad.
I couldn't feed that.
Oh my god.
Oh, I couldn't help him.
Or I was gonna...
I was gonna go back and help
The mini art attack I ain't
Wow get in my bubble all right What all right I want let my
rocket heal but
All right
Whoa, who died?
Here we go.
Don't wait!
I'm a...
I mean, that's a lot of old stuff.
That's a lot of...
That's a lot of old stuff.
Alright, I guess I swap off.
I...
This might be...
Why did you just do that?
Not gonna lie, that was just...
We're not gonna talk about it.
Wait, what happened?
Alright, it's okay.
I don't need super ice.
Ah, maybe I do.
I just thought maybe extra damage?
Question mark?
There you go.
Oh, that was the clone.
I was like, guys, I did it!
out of there no i need a plus one on the left hello
oh why are you going there oh my god i can flank behind and
kill someone you want to just keep pushing your brains guys
guys it's not me that doesn't make i'm not not me i did my
job i did my job yeah yeah i'm doing my job everybody let's
go standing there this is not spark top five guys i have a
feeling i have a feeling guys this might not be a top 500
game everyone's so mad it's all right it's okay we'll give
gomez a life we'll give gomez a get out of oh you want
rocket oh they're on rocket they just pull hold first point
and easy this might be a bottom 500 game yeah yikes i mean
technically i ain't a raccoon but I don't know how I feel
about Marvel Rivals 2.
Like, the Jimmy, I feel like I'm playing Quick Play.
Not gonna lie.
I do feel like I'm playing Quick Play right now.
These games have been, like, weird.
Did it.
Like, this does not feel very serious.
Yeah, I do feel like I'm playing Quick Play.
Everything just feels like, you know, like, these games have
been, like, wild, you know?
They're trying to get nest on the right.
All these games have just been, like, wild over up.
I would like everyone to, like...
Oh, my God, why?
Okay.
I got two, I got two, I got two.
Just find a point.
Please please please Oh my god, please
It's okay Oh my god all I'm doing is healing You're okay,
you're okay, you're okay, you're okay, you're okay You're so
healthy Okay, there you go We're all okay
Oh my god, I need to clap I need to clap I need to start
clapping.
You're also low.
I need to start clapping.
Clap clap Say it loud.
Say it loud.
Get healed.
Kill Bucky.
Got you.
Somewhere else.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Get healed.
All right, there you go.
Holy shit.
Jesus Christ oh my god can I can I peek oh I have to grab
armor I'm trying force defensive here
oh I wish I did not do that oh I hope she's a oh all right
so I thought me first I don't I don't know about that one.
I don't know about that one.
I...
I'll know about that one.
I guess I'm not.
Alright, well...
The sidewalk's gonna start a little thing and then that's...
Okay, wait.
Alright.
I gotta start stacking here.
Oh, I should not have used clap.
It's okay, I can grab it back right here.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, I looked overweight.
I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
One HP out.
I looked away.
Okay.
Do I have clapping time?
I do.
Oh, I forgot about this.
I'm, like, waiting for it to...
All right, that's awkward.
Oh, that's very awkward.
That's so awkward.
Oh, that is so awkward.
Don't worry, guys.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Well, that's awkward.
I wait.
I did not.
I was like, where the fuck did that okay they still have i
realized sidelog was gone so i was just like oh wait and i
was like i can be like more aggressive and then the strange
ult is what oh hey hello i'm a little scared i'm a little
scared i don't really want to go there this is really hard
for me We had like no cover there
We have like no cover we have no cover right now.
I guess the simple geometry
Oh, he might be dead
I don't want to be here.
I don't want to be here I do not want to be here Do not want
to be here I do not want to be here We're walking down.
We run here.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
I just see, like, so many, like, practical effects right
now.
Guys, I don't... I think Joki doesn't want to be here.
Oh, shit.
Well, I am first, I guess.
first okay okay
what is that what is oh shit oh that's a dead guy you have
the portal there you go I don't want to use that yet I know
I still had HP
That's right!
Where are you gonna?
Oh!
No!
Give him that reset, man!
Oh!
Got a point.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm gonna blame, we gotta blame our Bucky.
This guy, like, front line three times in a row.
Yes and no, but like no key we could when we gave this guy
like eight resets and we had Luna also Yeah, so where I
remember my all this might see this time I will say I never
had a need to use it if you think about it waiting waiting
waiting I should use it now Oh, this is bad.
We don't have all we don't have all we don't have anything
We have nothing.
We use.
I don't know where I'm positioning right now.
Alright, that's fine.
Ready?
That's fine.
I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping!
I'm hoping!
You don't have another!
Alright.
You could stay close Wait, there's someone
Oh, this is bad We got res nice Yeah, I've always believed
I've always believed
Do not worry
I've always believed I Never doubt it for a second
Unfortunately I have to avoid you guys My teammate does not
want to play with any of you again I'm sorry
I'm avoiding the woman.
Top 500, baby.
Right there.
Told you.
What can I say?
What can I say, guys?
I don't know.
I guess I can't say.
Wow, I guess only one woman per team.
That, wait, now that, switch the split.
I don't want heroes.
I wish Captain America can twerk.
What's the point?
Wait, there's custom.
customizable colors what's different oh it's his arm bend
what do you mean why you guys know damn well why i ask all i
could do is me can play basketball let me go and swoosh oh
whoa look at
I can't be balling.
Yo, he's balling right now.
Wait.
Am I...
Wait, the sit emote?
Oh, I think I have the sit emote.
I'm pretty sure I do.
Alright, let's see.
Wow!
I've seen enough.
enough.
You know, I told you.
Whoa!
What a time.
It used to go through the... Damn.
I understand lads now.
I understand.
Does it?
I don't think it does.
Not anymore.
That got nerfed.
That's right.
Pat.
That's freedom right there.
Welcome to America.
He's serving his country, guys.
He's serving his country.
Go on.
Do it for America.
He's packing for real.
Which is not the same.
The moment he can twerk, I'll feel better.
He'll...
me twerking a Captain America.
He's serving for shit.
I
got this associate.
This is why I hate being in the high elo.
I just have to watch him dance.
Jeff!
I didn't even know what was going on in 80% of that game, of
all of my games.
What the fuck was happening?
How did I get here?
I didn't even...
What happened?
I was so confused!
Was that show called Naked and Afraid?
That was me.
Oh yeah, I could go to the beach.
I forgot about the beach.
How do I go to the beach?
Alright, don't worry everybody.
I got...
Wait.
I have a swimsuit eye.
up and ready for battle wait where is everybody is everyone
at the beach i think everybody went to the there's nobody in
town square they're all at the beach how how do i get to the
beach where's the uber where is the uber oh there it is
all right here we go Going to the beach.
Hello, everyone.
Oh.
Goodbye, everyone.
This is the beach.
It's a bad...
Goodbye, everyone.
Oh, hey, Flamie.
Oh, shit.
I don't belong here.
I...
Is that right?
Who is the other one?
Is that...
Is that Mark?
Bro, that might be Rai.
I'm sure that's Rai.
That Rai?
Rai.
Bro, he's the only one that reps that shit.
I swear.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm ready to play this game.
I just wanted to check out the new season.
Who's who?
I just wanted...
to try out the new season we went too far we're in too deep
i'm in but like yeah i can't i can't i'm in too deep now
wait how do you help the mrc number one i don't even know
what's going on that's only mine wait then who is it who is
that was number six wait no i'm numbers no the emir that
wasn't what i don't want to reveal themselves i want to see
who it is i'm so confused don't reveal themselves watch it
be hogs bro smh smh but oops stop for 100 i don't know i'm
fucking wow it better not be hogs i will actually run this
I got you.
Got you.
I don't know what to play, so I got you.
I got the nuts in.
What even is better?
Is bombardment better?
Or the nuts?
I feel like the nuts only because, like, they get a cooldown
reduction.
Bombardment is better?
What?
What are you calling?
Whoa, all right
Bombardment I don't fucking know guys As I'm I'm
experiencing all these at the same time as you guys Who
fucking knows?
This is my spot get out here.
Oh my god, there's so many Who knows?
Oh shit, we might need...
Oh shit.
You think they're gonna get...
Oh.
Why are you gonna top this?
I'm right!
We're anti-topping!
Baby!
Stop this!
That's right!
Where did he go?
All we gotta do guys is AFK.
Oh wait, it's not about VP, never mind.
We're still AFK, but...
Alright.
you're welcome when he's he's hitting my res guys someone
stop him what who are who is this oh impunity and matna who
are these people oh wait wait my team is full of pros i
don't know dummies do you know any people yeah who the fuck
is the is it also player that took the mrc number one who
are these people You!
I don't know,
I think I wasted that.
All right.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm just, I'm chucking things out.
Abidement!
Oh, I'm slinging by left.
I'm slinging by left.
Like, I'm far left, I think.
It's okay, it's okay, we're all five.
Oh, what happened?
What's going on?
Wait, but Barman's pretty good.
The cooldown's crazy on it.
Oh, hey, he's whiny.
No, I think this is a little unfair.
No, yo, our team might be like very unfair.
Our team might be very broken.
I
can hold this for the only thing.
Oh, we don't need to do that.
Uh-huh.
We can rock it all in.
All right, let's go
Abidement I just won I just won the fucking teammate gotcha
right now What the my entire team is pro player and then
they have whiny Oh, is there momentum on Helena?
Oh, I feel bad All they have is whiny
That's unfortunate.
Ah, shit.
I'm back.
Am I okay?
Is someone we'll save here?
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
The current score is...
Don't see it now.
Fear.
Yeppy!
Never punished!
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Let's go.
I didn't, I had no fear.
Can't believe I'm a console MRC winner in my game.
Like that.
Gomez, get me a thing low.
What?
Gammy.
They say hello.
Who said hello?
Gammy.
Hi Gammy.
Who's Gammy?
Oh, here you go.
I just want to see if it'll charge up.
Come on.
Alright.
Yeah, someone go Punisher.
What if I go Punisher?
Who's Gamby?
I don't know Gamby.
Omega?
Love?
Oh no, I got you.
I got you all the way.
Oh no, I'm no one with Punisher, so I'm TP.
No, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
What's the point of me playing Rocket?
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't want to play her.
My turn.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I was gonna go through a TP and maybe save myself.
What the fuck?
Wait, yeah!
I did that!
I did- guys, do I see?
Guys, did I see that?
I did that.
Do you guys see that?
Nice one.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, I did that.
You wanna know who did that?
It was me!
because I've been lagging like the entire time.
Guys, guys, did you see that?
I did that.
Did you guys see it?
I just want to be sure you guys saw it.
Yeah, you did that.
GG.
One, two, zero.
Harry says you're a cutie pie.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
It's a worry.
Remember, you're the biggest learning curve for the game
since launch, and launch at least the betas and such.
Thank you.
I do it again.
I missed it.
But it's too late.
Now you'll never get to see that today.
Like how you win and pull the gotcha team?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Pure skill.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
It's skill that I...
Okay, now I get to go to the beach.
Yippee!
Hello, everybody!
I'm here at the beach.
Wow!
Hello!
Oh my god, look at all these giant women and Loki.
Wait, there's an Emma?
Oh, yeah, there is.
I remember it was like...
It's like right here, right?
Where is... Oh, oh!
I'll never get... No, that's Jeff's Beach Resort.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I failed the gotcha this time.
Um.
We might have lost the good...
We might have lost the gotcha this time around.
I think there's like five pro players on the end.
to be team.
Live by the gotcha.
Die by the gotcha.
Oh.
You know, it was nice while it lasted.
I'm surprised I had a streak that long.
Honestly, I'm surprised they gave us they let us do this for
that long.
The game has even start guys i just saw five top 500 uh
banners and the pro icons on the enemy team and i saw one
top 500 icon on my team wait hella no more is good now right
get rid of hella or like either one of them i don't know
which one's more annoying we don't know either surely guan
guan was let stop i wonder If they run Hell of the Moor,
this is your fault.
Guys, we saw last game, guys.
We saw what happened last game.
All right.
What do I want to play?
You know why?
Because I'm being shameless and looking at Flemay's stream.
Because I see them playing Hell of the Moor.
They don't have the boss.
I am lucky.
Goddess of mischief.
Come on.
You know what?
Fuck yeah, I'll give you the team up.
What do you want?
I trust I trust you man I trust you I want to play oh
fucking no come on do it
let's go we have a miracle I see they have triple DPS damn
shameless also I just heard him I just heard him across as
well get ready all right this stream sniped It's okay, they
don't know.
There's no streamers on our team.
Yes.
There's no streamers.
This is just a really big Discord hangout.
What the fuck?
Yeah, baby kittens.
What the fuck are you just saying?
Hey, baby kittens.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Woo-hoo!
I'm done.
Whoa, keep...
Wow!
I don't want to go there.
Oh, it's...
I don't want to be there anymore.
I'm scared.
Guys, remember when I said that I'm very scared?
About the enemy.
Um...
Guys, if you're joining at the raw moment, I had a six-game
win streak, guys.
I had a yellow carpet.
I had...
The keyword is had, but it was there.
Okay?
Like...
It was there!
It was it was cool!
It was so cool!
It was...
When it went... It was so cool, guys.
It was so cool.
I want to use my...
I feel like I can't use it at all.
I, I, guys, I, I have no confidence, no way we're like, just
believe, this is one of those moments where I think, I think
believing might not work this time.
Oh yeah, no, their entire team's pro, except for their
Spider-Man.
They're, oh no, they did one thing.
They're doing what they did to me.
White Fox here.
They're tag teams, bro!
I wonder what that...
It's not fair!
Oh my god.
Guys, it might be over.
Guys, hey guys, hey guys, oh we might have lost a teammate
RNG, guys.
There's a maybe, there is a maybe.
Oh my god, oh my god, just surrender.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What?
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, let's go.
Let's hope I don't die from this.
Let's hope.
Let's hope this doesn't kill me.
Don't.
Oh Oh Oh my
god, please I'm so scared Oh, no No How could we no No
Not more of this!
The torture continues.
The gap.
Oh my god.
There's stat padding.
Why?
No, I couldn't do anything.
I got dragged up.
Why?
I'm dead.
I'm not dead.
No!
Get me out of this lobby!
Why did we camp?
Why did we not leave the point?
Wait!
Why did we leave the point?
Why would you do this to me?
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
Guys.
Why are we here?
Oh, why are we here?
here why are we here
i just saw him i don't think it's gonna work y'all i don't
think it's gonna work
we're forcing a hulk thor into penny triple penny helen no
more comp i shine in darkness
all right we might have to say ggs you beat that by swapping
and you don't force your one trick every single fight it's
actually quite easy thank you guys just free me just let me
free me
It's just a freebie.
I want to go Mantis.
What if I go Mantis?
Maybe.
Maybe that's how what we do.
What if we just go Mantis?
I don't
know.
not winnable at all, so I'm just going whatever the fuck I
want.
Hey guys.
Don't worry, I'm here now.
Is everything okay over there?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Go.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, it's no longer fine.
It is no longer fine.
It...
It's no longer fine.
Alright, maybe Mantis was not it, guys.
Maybe...
Maybe Mantis was not it, everybody.
Maybe I'll go...
Maybe...
Oh.
Could have quit.
Let's go, Kurok.
Let's go.
You think my Invis will be okay?
Oh.
Oh, that's my bet.
That's...
I don't know.
I don't know what to...
There's no sense.
There's no salvaging this.
There is actually no salvaging this.
It's just we're just playing.
We're just playing what we want to play Why didn't we
surrender?
Why did we go through more of this?
Why?
Why did you take me here?
Yes, it wasn't me
Like, what was I supposed to do?
What?
Look, I had it too good for too long.
I had it too good.
Why make the pay?
This was self-inflicted.
100%.
All charged up and ready for battle.
Oh my god, we're already in.
all right three more games guys oh my okay wait wait wait
wait there's i see two i see they have four i see two on my
side i see i see two on my side can't be that bad we're
gonna play now who am i gonna vanish from this match no try
i don't know what i feel like all meta right actually need a
p i need a p it'll be fine
i'm gonna run some adam stuff i think we've been adam
okay we yeah we did forget yambit let's do gambit i'm back i
knew i would make it in time
see i told you uh middling papa smurf on well they give a
super chat they get thank you oh they pad mantis i was gonna
go man asking if you're paul the baker 96.
all right now we have rocket what goes well with rocket the
hell is paul the baker 56.
someone thinks that's your alt or something i don't know
what this game and since it's 5.5 do i guys what do i what
do i what do i ultron wait does all no ultron's gonna be
like hell Oh, that's the British tree on my team.
Oh, I don't want to play.
I don't know.
I'll play it all now.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, what?
I've got British tree on my team.
Is that British tree?
Oh, no.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon.
I want to play.
I'll be with this.
I don't know.
I have no idea which I'm going to play.
play invis no we technically have three more games guys i
just don't know i don't know what to play anymore what do i
i know if the maze gets gonna play a jubilee because he's
practicing oh my god it's okay we're five we're okay we're
here i hear a squirrel girl
Wanna drop down
Don't worry You're so healthy I hear so many noises I hear
so many noises right now And I'm scared
Okay we're fine We're fine I just hear too many noises
Everybody be fine Oh shit Bro.
There you go.
Oh my god!
Please!
Jesus Christ!
Is everybody okay?
Oh, everybody was not okay.
Is this RMP?
I don't triple support.
Which is good for me.
Alright.
I'm gonna tear up soon.
I just see my upgrades, I promise.
Oh shit, nice, nice, that's a good up.
Good up, get up!
I'm so scared, I hear so many noises right now.
I got scared, I'm sorry, I got...
We're trying!
Oh my
god!
God, someone save us!
Oh!
That's okay.
It's okay.
Wait, are we portaling?
No!
Okay.
Never mind.
It's no longer, okay.
Alright, I don't know if I should stick in Viz.
I feel like I should swap.
I don't know what to swap.
I guess Fox?
I guess white fox because of the dive.
I'm not wondering, is it try it?
Yeah, I'm thinking about swapping.
There we go.
Oh my god, there's so many things happening on my screen,
but it's not as bad as I saw it as bad as the other games.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
I'll just be here.
There we go.
What are you aiming at?
Oh, what are they aiming at, though?
Is everything okay over there?
Because I...
Wait.
Nice.
Sorry.
I'm so overwhelmed right now.
I am so overwhelmed, guys.
I am...
I am so...
Let's go.
That's all of them.
All of them are going to go.
All of them are
going to go.
Oh, God.
Please, I need all charge.
Okay, I'm going to stop going this.
Oh, God.
Guys, please.
I'm backing up.
Slowly backing up.
Please live.
Oh, God.
That was...
Holy shit.
Okay, I lived.
Bitch, I lived.
I lived.
That could have gone.
Really, really bad
It's going really really bad now
No, never mind This guy got really really bad there's
nothing to block it and it did oh, he's not the kill Adam
Yeah, I can face him.
I'm gonna kill him
Oh shit.
That's bad.
What's up, Rocket?
I tried.
I had to protect our rocket for so long.
Okay.
Someone tied down!
Goodbye.
The fact that you ran away from point than touching when we
have a pop-up.
Oh shit.
Or maybe this will help maybe I don't know
It was working until it stopped working so I can't tell
Where are we getting hit from I can't What's hitting us like
what
What's hitting us
Oh I can't play this character.
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I can't do anything.
It's too good.
Everything, anything, and everything.
I felt like I was just getting shot by everything around me.
And then nobody decides to jump in the moment I swapped the
white fox.
Everyone just decided not to not to run in.
I don't know.
Let's just...
Ah, fuck it.
Guys, I think the wind streets...
I think it's downhill from here.
guys it might we might be downhill from here
let's try jubilee i don't think jubilee is i don't know
jubilee i heard jubilee's pretty meh guys it was so nice
knowing what it's like to be a winner for a second It felt
so good to feel like a winner For six games in a row I got
too close to the top 500, son I did
Okay, Kevin Okay, all right, Kevin That's fine I'm making a
comeback That's fine, Kevin.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna play real DPS.
Oh,
you're not doing anything.
I don't know.
I think, guys...
I think you're...
Guys.
I don't... guys.
Oh, I thought I could hit that.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Oh,
my god.
Oh, my god.
That's alright.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Like, I don't know, guys.
I- I- whoa!
What's- what's going on?
I don't know.
Stuff's happening.
I want to heal you guys, but like, you're making it very
hard for me.
Alright, cool.
That's cool.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that's not nice.
That...
That's not nice for me.
It's okay, they born again!
It was- it's born- it's alright, born again!
They wasted it!
There we go.
You're welcome.
You're- you're welcome.
welcome.
There you go.
You're welcome.
Oh.
That sure bit.
Hey guys, I would really like help with this Venom.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna use this.
It's alright.
We're so healthy for now.
It's so...
Oh my god, where did my cloak go?
Where's my cloak healing?
I need a note.
Wait, where's my cloak?
A cloak!
Fuck me, I guess.
Yeah, fuck you!
Oh, you want heals?
Wow!
It must be nice.
Yeah.
Yeah, you like that heals?
You like the peel I gave you?
Just take as Luna.
Thank you so much.
How?
Oh, it's because of the bubble.
Oh my god, it's because of the fucking magic sparkling shit
or whatever.
Just get me out of here.
Take me home.
Country road.
I'm using this on myself.
Fuck this.
I'm no longer.
No longer am I giving snowflakes to teammates.
No longer!
What?
I was gonna say, how do...
How did I, like, not freeze him there?
Oh my god.
This is too much, man.
This is...
It's, I'm, it's over.
Oh yeah, I forgot my fox, guys.
I'm getting absolutely fucked up right now.
It's hard to use my C when I keep getting absolutely fucked
up.
You don't understand.
Ah shit, goodbye.
A good fight.
That was unlucky.
Get me out of here.
Hey, they might avoid me.
They might avoid me.
And then...
And that means...
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no!
I pressed Q.
I was gonna press Q.
It's okay.
This time I blame myself.
That was on me.
I was about to press Q.
What the fuck?
Let me out of this person.
I'm glad it's okay.
At least the game didn't go into a longer extended.
You know?
I was gonna press Q too.
I didn't think... I didn't see the Elsa, too.
It's okay.
I had it too good for too long.
Yeah!
I hope they avoid me.
See who would cleanse that?
Oh my god.
That was not a meme.
I don't think it was winnable.
Even if I queued that, I will say.
In the overarching game experience, I don't think we would
have won.
I literally don't think we would have won the overall game.
It was just delaying the inevitable, I feel like.
Oh, no.
I've won too many games.
I'm being punished now.
I mean, I'm actually being punished now.
Wait, let's see.
Divine punishment.
Why do they get all the Celestials?
The SVMM.
No!
They're like No top 500 for you You were the one that didn't
want it You didn't want it You complained
I can't believe it They treated me so well They welcomed me
back with open arms Be like welcome back to rivals, Doki
Welcome back to rivals.
Do you like winning?
I know you like winning.
Now you're in too deep.
Now you can't pull out.
It's too late.
Well, I guess I'll go.
Let's see.
Maybe Adam?
Wait.
Okay.
All right.
We're like this, right?
And then we'll have the team up.
Then we'll have, yeah.
Oh, shit.
We're bringing it back, baby.
They closed the door.
I had too much of a good time.
Now the door's closed.
All right.
I still feel his presence.
I remember it all too well.
Okay, let's see.
I heard siloed was pretty broken, too.
Created cosmic not provides healing.
Okay, so only this provides healing, right?
Only the right click.
I will bring peace to this universe, no matter the cost.
Just want to be sure.
Yeah, only the right click.
All right, here we go.
All right, all right, here we go.
Let's see how I haven't played Adam in so long.
Just say It's been 80 years since I played Adam
Oh, don't worry don't worry.
Oh my god.
I think I might need to do this Oh, we don't have enough
damage
We don't have enough damage for shit.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy, guys.
Aww, that's alright.
Are we fine?
Fly away.
Is everybody...
Oh my god, please.
What's going on?
Jesus Christ!
Oh, I didn't see it.
That's my bad.
Oh, this is bad for me.
Oh, no.
Okay, I gotta kill.
I gotta kill.
That's five.
Please kill the Luna!
Oh my god.
Please!
Jesus.
Oh my god.
This is the only thing I can do.
We just don't have enough damage.
Oh my god!
What's going on?
I couldn't get out.
I could not get out.
They take us and they give us me Okay, alright Oh,
I should have went I should have went strange, but at this
point It's too late We don't need strange Guys, I
guys oh no I'm
just healing fuck it I'm just gonna heal I'm
just I'm just healing at this point I'm just healing okay
it's okay it's okay everybody are we YOLO kit.
There we go.
Nice.
Assembling.
All right.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
Guys.
I don't know.
don't have all guys I don't have all we might be fucked we
don't have a third support up
okay all right this is why I can't oh my god oh shit it's
five I'm cocooning
What's going on?
Yay!
I don't know I don't know I don't know I don't know we're
here we're here I know we got a bunch of mutes on this team
but if we just call it no more bubble I will kill them every
fight there's like four times I'm just there's so many I
what's going on things are happening I think I think I won
the round.
Guess not.
I don't feel like I'm winning, though.
I don't think you won the round.
All right.
We're here.
I won the round, but I won.
Guys, you can sort of tell I haven't played Adam in maybe
like five plus seasons.
I didn't.
Wow Well
Okay All right
Let's fuck it All right
Okay there you go it's fine Is that a Jubilee?
Is that a fucking Jubilee?
They're right.
All right.
Oh, God.
There you go.
I got you
It's fine.
We have bad results.
It's okay.
Stuff is happening.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Whoa, whoa, okay.
Would they be fine?
They'll be fine.
All right, now...
I...
This game...
This game is so different now.
That's all I can say.
This game...
This game is so...
This...
This is ranked at top 500.
Okay.
if you guys want to know this is what top 500 games are like
whoa oh don't whoa don't get me out of here it's all right
Get ready!
Don't fly!
Don't!
Stop!
Okay.
Yeah.
Easy, too easy.
I did it
Yeah There we go There we go Not even close I even We did it
We did it We rest We rest The very theory was not It was a
little It was a little scary at first I will say Oh, hey,
there you go.
It was a little scary at first.
It was...
One last game.
I was...
I did doubt a little bit.
It was a little bit of doubt in there going in.
Just...
Just a...
Just a little bit.
Okay.
But, but hey, hey, look, who cares about that?
I won.
I, it's, it's who, hey, hey, but I won the game.
I won the game.
Oh, okay.
Which hero do you think you're going to...
All right, this will end it in hell.
I haven't been in this Elo in so long I
haven't been in this Elo in in so I take no just Wow it
still feels like quick play even in this lobby even in this
in this, in this Elo, it still feels like I'm playing Quick
Play, not gonna lie.
Like, this doesn't feel real.
These games don't feel like I'm playing Rink right now.
Unless, like, I'm against a full stack of pros, then I, then
it's very noticeable.
But, like,
but, like, I don't know, maybe this one will be it.
I know Doom's a pro player.
Yeah, I'm fighting my inner D.
I'm every game every game.
I'm fighting my inner demons
Like I feel like nobody knows what's going on Honestly and I
yes What goes well Jubilee?
I don't know maybe is Jubilee a main healer or not?
Because I don't know I don't Does anyone...
Is Jubilee a main heal or a flex heal?
Because I can't tell...
Can I play Mantis?
Is off heal?
Okay, I say no.
So what if I go Groo- I go- wait, not Groo- What should I go
then, Luna?
Maybe Luna with...
Uh...
With Snowflake?
Don't do that.
I'll do Luna with Snowflake.
Are you...
All right, we'll see how this goes.
I have no idea what to play.
All right, the last game.
Whatever happens.
This is last game.
Yeah.
Ouch.
That did hurt.
I don't know where to position myself there.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Did I help him?
No, I did not.
I thought I had...
Oh, shit.
I have to reload.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know about the hulk.
Let's not force double dive tanks or double melee into that.
I think we're going to force it.
Guys.
I think we might be forcing it, guys.
I
think we're forcing it, guys.
I...
This looks like something we're forcing, guys.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
There's too many things.
the hand!
I'm dead to this.
Oh, yeah!
Guys.
I...
I don't know, guys.
No, no matter what happens, guys, we're ending here.
No matter what.
Damn, I hope we don't...
I hope we don't...
I hope we don't double support us.
We did it!
Let's go!
All right, three...
Two...
One...
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
I'm alive.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, Jubilee.
He's jumping everywhere!
He was jumping everywhere!
I can go back then.
Oh.
where is my there you go maybe I can please peek me please
peek me I'm so scared for you oh my god oh my oh my god oh
my god what's going on this is the entire game the entire
game is me going and something's happening okay
rivals rivals we rambling we're rambling oh
my god he's so low he's so low We're rivaling!
We're rivaling!
We are rivaling!
We are... Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's okay.
If he goes to me, he's technically throwing.
Oh, no.
That's good, that's good.
We're rivaling, we're rivaling, we're rivaling, we're
rivaling.
We are rivaling.
We are still rivaling.
Oh, my God.
Rivaling is going on right now.
Oh, I hope that's not on me.
Oh, whoa.
Wow.
Well.
Um...
Yeah...
I'm...
Wait, where's the...
I'm rivaling so hard right now!
Only 60 seconds left!
Turn into the tree of the world!
Egg drizzle!
I'm rambling so hard!
Okay, it's fine.
It's no longer fine.
I'm getting away from that.
I...
All right.
That's okay.
Oh my god, where is that coming from?
Where is that coming from?
Oh, fuck, no.
Oh, no.
This might be it for me.
There's so much rivaling.
Is it the rivals we made along the way?
Is it the rivaling?
Oh, my God.
The right heroes could make all Oh, no, yes.
All right.
I think I rivaled
the rival.
The rival.
I'm rivaling so hard.
I believe that we will win.
I...
That's a lot of rivaling.
I don't think I got exiled.
I never...
I never got exiled, though.
Will be coming in?
I don't know.
I never got...
I guess I could make...
I was just like...
I never got exiled.
Only once?
Maybe.
I don't remember.
I don't think I had my...
Oh, two at that time.
Or I had my thing.
It's just hard because it's like double dive tank, too.
There you go.
I cleansed us.
I'm doing it.
I just, guys, did you see that?
I cleansed us.
Okay, that I don't know now.
I don't know.
I can't cleanse us twice.
I can't cleanse us again.
I I
Guys I did cleanse I did cleanse but I don't know if I
should I don't know if I should keep playing Luna into this
I'm on back here
He had to it was the only way
It's better use my clap I would have used my clap.
This is bad.
Yeah.
Don't worry, you're cleansed.
You're not cleansed.
Don't worry.
I did not cleanse you.
Oh, I hear.
Oh, God.
Oh, I don't have cleanse.
I do not cleanse.
I do not have cleanse.
I do not have clearance guys.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, shit.
I can't!
He blocked me!
Okay, I didn't have my ult yet.
Can't blame me, I didn't have my ult yet.
I cannot.
All right, go, go, go.
We're walking in.
All right.
Oh shit.
There we go.
Oh my god, that was close.
That was close.
I almost killed that guy.
I almost killed my teammate.
all right here we go guys I don't know this game seems a
very
I'm sure you're gonna want to fall by now.
Oh.
Thanks so much.
Now help me.
Us against the world.
We're here.
Oh my god, I don't think we live that.
I do not think we live that.
I don't think we live that.
Um, I, I wish we had that up, you know?
Oh my god, all right, whoops.
Couldn't do that.
Yeah, I, uh, uh, I, legitimately, this is last game, and,
yeah, this feels,
yeah, I'm just, I, I don't know.
I, I don't know.
I don't know.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, come on.
Please.
Is my teammate here?
Okay, so we don't have any support ults.
So we're a bit fucked.
We don't have any support ults right now.
I feel like I had to use that because...
Yeah.
Okay.
Damned if I don't, damned if I do type situation, you know?
There we go.
Alright.
Cleanse!
I think?
Oh no!
Okay.
Let me hope that...
That's unlucky.
That's unlucky for us.
Our Hulk, I think our Hulk threw there.
Our Hulk actually threw there.
Oh, that's so unlucky.
Oh.
Our Hulk threw.
He pushed up so far for no reason.
Why?
Two, two, three.
It was like in their spot.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
That's so unlucky.
Guys, I can't.
This was...
I just wanted to do my plate.
It's okay.
I think...
wait wait god damn it got we we were all almost there wait
I'm not damn it that one loss I'm ranked seven five nine
fuck you I'm top 800 though I am
I am one game away I am I am one game away technically I I I
I'm one game away from top 500 though if you think about i'm
so jealous of that table oh they was super chat thinking
guys i am one game away i what no this is one game away this
is one game away this is one game away
all right all right ggs go eat sushi
oh shit all right let's go that's why i have one game away
though i don't know what i am then you'll be two well when
i'm two games away i give up that's when i'll give up all
right i
know when i give up oh it's doomed again
Lock in.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Okay, what?
Whoops, I didn't mean to do Deadpool.
No, I want to do a rocket.
We'll do bombardment.
You got the Wolverine guy from season zero?
Let's go.
No, I'm one game away guys.
It's what guys.
It's one game away.
We're just one game away.
Yeah, this is it.
I can feel it.
I can feel the one game.
That's what they all say.
Guys, this is it.
Guys, this, this, this moment.
This is that moment where we're one game away.
This is it.
All right.
Guys, here we go.
Here, the one game, guys.
This is LG for real.
For real.
No matter what happens.
This is LG.
Right here.
Right now.
Guys, you are watching a historical moment right now.
This is a historical moment that you're witnessing today.
Yeah, what?
Are you playing tanker now?
No, don't get it.
Don't trust me.
I don't want to play the rocket.
All right, here we go.
This moment, we're going to be part of history.
History is in the making for this one moment in our life.
LG stands for let's game, not last game.
Go out to you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Doug, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
VOD watchers skip four hours ahead for actual game.
Oh, sorry, I was looking at chat.
Really, nobody's gonna do that.
Guys, this is LG for real, and then we'll come back to this
game two months later.
When games get easier.
Don't worry.
We'll come back.
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay over there?
Are you guys?
Oh my god.
What is going...
Are you guys a-okay?
Oh my god.
I see so many...
Wow!
Everyone is...
Bombard!
Actually, bombard.
I forgot about bombardment.
I'm still getting...
Look, I'm still getting used to this.
Guys, I'm still...
still getting used to this, okay?
I'm getting trying to get used to this whole thing.
This is all still so new to me.
I nearly delivered it.
That's much better.
Oh my, I'm not used to it at all, guys.
These team ups, Figma jigs and everything.
I need to put in the res.
Abignment!
Okay, it's okay.
I'm doing my job.
Don't worry, I can bombardment any moment now.
Bombardment is... is loaded, locked and loaded.
Also, the bombardment is so...
Cool down is like...
Oh shit, pressed E accidentally.
I was trying to...
Okay, let's hope that nobody dies here.
Because I had fucked up.
Nice.
all right we're doing it one all right here we go where's he
trying to do he's trying to punch a raccoon please he's
trying to punch a raccoon what was the plan wait okay i was
gonna say i know you can make a hole
It's all right.
I'm just a little raccoon.
Look at me go.
Look at me go doing my little raccoon things.
Oh, am I helping?
Am I?
Oh, am I...
Oh.
Well, we lost two I think I'm helping Okay, I bombardment
again
There we go Bombardment, oh my that's us that's us.
That's us.
Okay, we okay We might have That might have been a little
bit it too many too many else right there just it's just
just a maybe my god a little too spicy over there no we used
uh angela and uh it's okay we stopped maga i'll let my i'll
let my luna build
What is he gonna do?
Oh!
Oh, that's...
Oh, that's awkward.
That's what he was gonna do.
Oh, that's insane.
We're tipping, we're tipping.
I did not realize there was a Wolverine right behind me.
I think we're five?
Do we not...
get off point do not get off point bombard it no
oh it's dope oh
would have been nice it would have been it didn't work
unfortunate it's okay it's okay we have the system though we
got the system down though it's okay we have the system oh
shit the way they do they have zero supports now all right
oh yeah that's right try and try and kill this oh never mine
that's right try and heal this
say other team has collab oh nope they got they got another
support never mind the other team has decided to regroup the
other team oh no oh that's oh that's oh in there's that's
not even in their spawn where are they where even is this
I don't even know where that is.
Oh, God.
Please don't die.
If you guys die, you'll be on the other side of the team.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Me and you.
No!
Me and...
I'm...
I'm in alive It's all right I told you now I live I I don't
know how but we'll we take those
We take those cats I'm trying
I can't do that much.
Go do your thing.
Go.
Yeah, I like it.
I didn't want to play the game anyway.
It's okay.
We have that.
Holy shit out.
How are people dying?
all right i see how people are dying um it's okay guess who
has bombardment i guess
it's okay
i'm existing i'm existing i'm existing as a person i i am
here i am here i'm all right someone's got shoot that though
there you go i'm helping i'm participating i'm participating
in the game i'm participating i'm participating as a player
there you go we are part of the game look at that easy it's
not over until it's so true so true you're doing something
i'm i'm do i'm participating I'm bombarding?
I'm bombarding.
Top-notch team to win this one.
Who are you calling a raccoon, huh?
We're existing.
Yeah.
We're...
Something's happening.
Something's happening on my screen.
This is where she's doing stuff.
Things are being done right now.
Thank you, thank you.
I know it's very hard.
to do what I was doing.
Yep.
It's very hard to do what I was doing there.
No worry.
Don't worry, guys.
I know.
I remember the shoot.
Stuff was happening.
It was.
I think if this game was first person, this would have been
hell, honestly.
I legitimately I would have left the game.
I would leave the match mid game.
I don't think I could do that.
I legitimately don't think I could play.
I could play this game in its first person.
It's a lot.
A lot of stuff going on in my screen.
There you go.
I'm doing my job.
Bombardment.
Whoa.
Stop.
Don't worry.
Bombardment in five.
Oh, please live.
Please live so I can start bombarding.
Bombardment!
Holy shit.
I'm at the...
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Bombardment in five.
It's coming back very soon.
Thanks for the boost.
holy shit oh my god that's a lot of damage though that like
what can i do what can i do there that's just me like
pouring everything into
all right here we go oh my god i'm breaking the shield i'm
breaking the shield please i'm trying so hard to break the
shield right now.
All right.
I'll just be over here.
I think it's fine.
I don't have to do anything.
But you guys are fine, right?
Like, I feel I'll use my ult.
You guys are fine.
But.
All right.
Goodbye, everybody.
Oh, they're gonna portal.
scarlet what the what the fuck were my teammates all right
oh my god they're all the way over there now who's gonna
look first do you see me i'm behind you oh i'll chuck this
over there oh i hope my teammates are gonna live oh they're
they're fine oh they're oh
We needed the Luna.
No, no, I need it.
It's the thought that counts, you know?
It's the thought that counts.
There we go.
If it works, it works, guys.
If it works, it works.
gonna no is he gonna make it yeah this is the top five this
is a top 500 game this is a um can you not remind you this
is a top 500 game um
yeah i told you all we need i swear i think it's gonna be
like 601 or some shit I bet you there's it's never this easy
it's never that easy I never get what I want I never get
what I want it was
not one game but go eat a sushi now now it's one game away
now all right
now we are oh wow la-di-da goomis gets the v-top 500 oh wow
good for him good la-di-da good for him must be nice
Hi.
Madara.
Don't do this to me.
Ah!
Don't do this to me, guys.
Don't you dare.
Uh, don't you dare.
Okay.
Don't, don't you?
This is true.
Guys, don't do this to me, guys.
You know I'm easily tempted.
You can bait me.
Bait me so easily.
You're so right, Nexi.
You're so right.
But the mask, it calls for me.
The mask.
But it's calling for me, though.
You're so right, though.
But you're so right.
Imagine the screenshot on Twitter.
I'm already 603!
that screenshot right now.
How did I lose?
I already lost five placements.
And like...
Zechra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, everyone's queuing up right now.
Surely maybe I'll get into like...
Maybe I'll maybe I'll get it guys guys guys Oh Madara is
finally said I feel like I'm playing a quick play But I'm
one game away from top 500 Lamount
Technically, oh wait no I lost I lost the people Yo get in
their game again against them don't say that guys but what
but what it is oh what it is huh uh wow
so let me look at everybody's in queue right now oh no one's
in queue personally i want to risk it guys but guys
Guys!
But guys!
You're right, the longer we wait, the further we are away
from top 500.
I got one more enemy.
Just guys, think about it, guys.
Guys, think about it.
Just...
I don't have anyone to do a whiff!
I'm gonna...
Everybody's in game!
No, Madara's droid already.
I'm pretty sure.
Can't even...
He has his stats like a little bitch.
Also, he's ranked 122.
You know, you guys always know what to say.
You guys always know.
I just need to wait.
I just...
Okay, wait.
Someone's calculating for me if I am one game away.
I have a gamer that's calculating for me.
Let me know if I am actually one game away.
I have to be.
There's no way.
Who's this person?
person you're
you are only gonna get further away you don't from if you
don't solo queue excel thank you the super chat thank you
but there's nobody in queue there's nobody in queue guys
guys i can't do that i'll just get fucked by matchmaking
your rick is dropping at the
So far
No, I'll do one I'll do quick like a cat.
I can't do this.
I but who cares who cares who cares?
I don't care about rank who who cares who cares who cares
But I do care, but I don't care.
I don't care Yes, you care
Oh, you're tough, but I don't care, but he, uh, Doki Bram
Bronson 3's mighty, I will do it with you, Orca, thank you
for the super chat, thank you, thank you, I don't care, I, I
don't care,
I don't care,
all right, okay, Okay.
I don't care.
Guy, who cares?
The voice.
This is it.
Fun, fun, fun.
No, I don't care.
I do not care.
I don't care.
I'm posting this tweet right now.
I'm up.
Thoughts on newest season.
Finish placements.
And almost got to top 500.
even though I did not know what was I did not know what was
going on I feel like I was playing quick extended quick play
I don't I just don't know what's happening on my screen but
somehow we're here
Oh shit, I got Madara.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, we got Madara.
We got Madara.
Wait.
Does this mean we are gonna lose?
Because you're always losing.
Okay.
Guys, Vatara says he's always losing.
It's too late.
I go missiles like, don't queue.
I got peer pressure.
You want to ban close?
I think it's like super OP for a side.
Wait, do I have a second support?
Oh, God.
Don't.
Okay, bro.
Just kidding.
Actually, don't.
It's the only spot I can play.
I can't.
out of those thoughts on newer season mario i was too
finished but got top out didn't know i did not know what was
going on i feel like i's playing extended quickly i just
don't know what's happening on screen but somehow we're here
it's okay i won't be don't worry and then i take like a two
like a five week sabbatical don't lie nexi thank you thank
you thank you i was peer pressured i didn't know what was
going on
guys i don't know what to do if all else fails go rocky i
think this is it i think this is the plan this is the plan i
got peer pressured guys
don't keep peer pressured that dragon is the peer pressured
Me exactly
Yeah, well, I couldn't I couldn't do anything about it.
I folded They had such they had a convincing argument That's
my birthday to do you can't get one game and I don't want
this is the one game when a happy birthday Thank you super
chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear win.
Yeah, happy birthday!
All right.
Are you ready to see me lose?
And then we'll be two games away.
Two games away.
Oops, that was an accident, honestly.
I'm just gonna do this.
I'm hooked.
Oh, bombardment!
Sorry, I fucked up my- I hope nobody dies there.
It's getting me awkward.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
I actually pressed- I have fat finger D.
This is not good.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Oh, this is not okay.
It guys.
This is not okay
This is bad.
I might be two games off.
This is bad This might this might be a two game scenario
guys I took the risk, you know sometimes you just gotta
gamble your life away just sometimes I can hit in a sec.
Sometimes life is a gamba.
Guys, sometimes you just...
You just got a gamba.
Oh,
there's nothing I could do.
Sometimes life is a highway.
exactly you miss all the shots you don't take guys sometimes
you just
oh we double support all of this
that's that's awkward that's That's awkward.
That's awkward.
This is rocking out in three, two, one.
Let's go.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, I didn't have it.
Guys.
I think...
I can't really tell.
Oh, shit.
Who's TPing?
He's trying to right-click.
Yeah, I'm looking at their mag.
Wait, who's TPing?
Okay.
Did we make it?
Oh.
What?
Fuck.
Are you in VC?
Guys.
You're good.
Are you in VC?
I just want to know if you're a VC, I didn't know you're in
VC.
I think...
I think, um...
Maybe.
Who told me to play one more game?
Who was it?
Who was- guys?
Guys, who was it?
Who was it?
It was not me.
Who did this to me?
Who- who was it?
It was Madara's fault.
You're right.
It was.
It was Madara's fault.
It was 100%.
You're right.
It was Madara's fault.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe voices told me to do this.
two one all you need to do is capture the mission area oh my
gosh i got over here i can't believe it
I'm about to hit in a sec, ready?
I'm walking on tanks, don't worry.
You're good.
Okay, on tank, walk up, boss.
Good, come back.
Come back.
Oh, that...
Man, abide me!
Oh, I should have.
Good point.
The missionary is yours.
Okay.
There you go
Nice they wasted up there thank God.
What is the X?
What do I oh it's where I sit on him.
I forgot about that team up I haven't seen that team up in
so long I don't want to be hooked They're just sitting here
Yeah, that was a good freeze I have brutal You're ready
Three, two, one It's five No more, no more, no more Yeah,
bombardment Bombardment Bombardment There you go Not moving
in time There you go Here you go Here you go We can hit with
a catful We can hit with catful Back up, back up I'm gonna
give I'm gonna give all trash sure Luna that's fine it's
fine we just sit with we just sit with the my old my buddy's
talking I'm so I'll let y'all know when ready looking walls
on Bucky when you're on top you're ready I'm trying to walls
on Emma Emma Emma Emma Bucky one Bucky one Bucky one Emma oh
shit I'm trying to make sure I'm up we have one after
Oh my god Oh my god Does Emma really want is she really one?
Oh, she was took this place He didn't get touched you wait
Oh my god, it's okay.
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
Yeah!
Husky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Husky.
It just became my birthday.
So can you throw it?
Husky, we can't, Husky, Husky, come on, Husky.
Come on.
You're going to make Madara cry.
Husky, we can't do this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Husky.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Guys, guys, guys.
In typical DOKY fashion, I'm going to get so close to
winning.
And then I'm going to lose it all.
I'm going to lose it all right here.
They gave me hope for one second in typical DOKY fashion.
It's got to happen.
I can feel it.
They always do this.
They gave me hope.
They gave me hope for one second.
Just take it away from me.
is capture the mission area got it if i lose it all i lose
it all
guys um i would love to farm this but i do need you yet I'm
a crippled game, sorry.
I'm off map, I'm off map!
Nice.
I'm about to hit him!
Good, good, good, good, good.
Holy shit, we're alive?
We're...
What?
Wolven, Wolven, Wolven.
Jason, Jason, Jason, I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with
you.
Nice, I look severe, walk, walk, walk, walk, I'm D, I'm D.
What happened to me?
I look for another spear.
Look, look, look.
He has a lot.
Bivine!
No, no, no, no.
Just gotta...
Wait, they cancelled the team by the way.
Back up, back up.
They're on thing now.
I'm on thing for you right now.
Alright.
Thing is walking the fire now.
Shoot this thing.
Can you run quick?
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
the RV.
Bombardment!
Help!
I'll catch you up.
Can I get a punch?
Look.
Bombardment!
I have what here.
We have a battle.
We're here early.
We can about...
You want to go through the first?
You want to go through the Kite?
Go to the Kite's portal.
Yo, DD right here.
What's DD?
Do you want to go first or my going first?
Me, me, me, me.
I can go.
All right.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Does he come back?
He does not come back.
Okay, that's okay.
It's fine.
I can just come with my ult.
You guys ready?
Three.
Where's my...
Just come in.
Look at the Luna.
I'm getting armor.
Oh shit.
Uh...
He didn't reply, he didn't can I, he didn't can I on point.
Yeah!
Put farm in, put farm in, put farm in.
We don't have a portal.
They're gonna have to use.
Stop points, stop points, stop points, stop points, stop
points.
I'll catch you up.
I have found one of them.
He's staying on, I'm back soon.
I'm back soon.
I'm on for now.
Yeah, I'm back in three, two, one, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on,
I'm on.
I'm chucking stuff in.
Take turns, take turns, take turns.
I'm on first, I'm on first.
I'm on first.
I'm on, I'm on next.
All right.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on
Okay, oh wait me I mean, okay, okay, okay, okay
That's fine, but huge fix wait for everyone to respawn help
our Luna help her Luna I don't think our Luna's gonna make
it I don't think our Luna's gonna make it Hit Luna without
and then we win with DD us rocket all right if we could get
it surely i can put mine are you slamming three two one okay
you're slamming they're slamming they're slamming i don't
think i can no we don't no look at the thing look at the
thing where oh my wait what's going on what's i i don't
I can't bombard this!
I'm trying!
They still have this portal.
That's fine, they use both DPS though, that's fine.
Yeah, yeah, we have to get those portals out before we do
combo.
Go with DPS full.
Oh no.
I'm gonna break my res here.
Kill the thing, kill the thing.
He jumped out.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, both I will No Just kill, just kill Our rocket's
out there We have to play with rocket on this fight Guys,
please Look behind
Oh no, I knew it I knew it, guys Walk high ground Guys, I
knew it Top right, top right, top right Did you have touch?
I should be.
Okay.
Rocket.
Marked.
Going in three, two, one.
I'm on point.
Go, go, go!
Look at their cloak.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, dead.
Cloak, dead.
Wolf DPS one.
Bring one.
Everyone one.
No more.
Wolf on.
No!
We're down to support.
They make portal.
I have a hold.
That's okay.
It's okay.
Kill the wolf.
Oh My god, they have a beautiful we have we have better we
have better Luna There you go, they're gonna have Luna next
after that thing.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Please pushing three two.
Oh, my god, oh my god.
Oh
Okay That's the strat the strat The strut!
Ah, the strut!
I used it!
I used the strut!
I fucking used it!
The ultra strut worked!
Oh, Shirley!
Shirley!
Oh, watch this!
Watch me be a five hundred and ten the moment of truth
i'm put i'm not playing one more i'm done i'm i'm getting
food
i'm like thank you and a 20 give the chip if a donkey just
want more Don't keep My guys, I need to eat I haven't had
dinner yet But don't keep just There's one more Never ending
one more Game Don't keep this is one more This is one more
I I
I can't
imagine It's literally one more Took you from my starving
child Just one more
Just one more God thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you We're actually going to confess how she played 20
more games.
Austria went to rank 1k.
Oh, yeah, alright.
Now you're pressuring me.
Oh, oh, guys.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, what's this, huh?
What is this pressure now, huh?
I thought you said you guys didn't pressure me.
This is not pressure.
okay i'll do one more off stream i eat and i come back and
then and then when i finish eating and i get that one more
and i win that one more i'll do the tweet
but doki you can get it on stream though doki don't you
imagine if you get top 500 guys we got so close this is
practically top 500 guys Like, no, I'll eat it.
But don't get, you can get it on stream.
All right, guys, guys, I'll do one more after I eat.
No one.
All right, anyway, guys, thank you all for coming.
I really appreciate you guys hanging out with me today.
Checking out Marvel Rivals 2.
It's like a whole, I feel like I'm playing a whole new
entire game.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause,
check, get up, and move around and get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve,
wait, I should get this screenshot first before it falls any
further.
Let me get this screenshot before it falls down anymore.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to head off and eat now.
I'll say yes, always everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check,
get up and move around and get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time.
everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.